et par rouge
comme axel
complètement et il faut qu'on trouve les
parties on est là haut il s'assied or on
allie attaque gars qui y est exact mais
c'est bizarre ces costumes perchés sur
des trucs comme ça bien vrai alors
ouais non c'est bizarre mais c'est
beaucoup quoi t'as vu le même hier
cherouana oui j'étais très heureux
j'étais très heureux du charroi main ont
lieu quatre vingt cas non je crois quand
on cherche ali quand même
de 4 des 5 ou 4 505
ben ouais c'est trois quatre cinq il lui
attaque le pion
à des audits petrov mais oui les amis
analyse très pertinente la de femmes
ne pouvaient choquer ne bouge pas
bah je sais pas
on va devoir se faire mal aux yeux pour
essayer d'écrire tout ce qui se passe
je vais pas le faire bouger mois en fait
on va voilà sa part
sa part fab seti par ouais bon petrov
celui de doudin doodle qui a dit
ce qui compte c'est de ne pas perdre
donc il veut faire des petites nul
bailly la pâte à un ben oui toujours su
il comprend très bien la stratégie quoi
on n'a pas les coûts pour l'instant mais
on à l'écran donc c'est pas grave on
voit que c'est une petrov ya le cube
foot au hand et 6 pour une torche on est
vite remarqué points 4
voilà qui va jouer ali a laissé 3 ou
ou des cuatro sûrement des cuatro mais
bon on ne sait pas
non la partie cinq regards c'est que
partie 4
désolé pour ce petit désagrément
on souffle un jeu attendu qu'on n'a pas
des trucs
pour le moment on n'a pas les coups mais
j'ai envie de te dire
[Musique]
brian is in the kitchen un ça va alors
ah ça y est on a des coups
tout d'un coup ils sont là
à mathieu qui excédé petrov partout ah
bah ça va être bien intéressantes comme
on les aime
il y avait un peu de frustration les
jours précédents de ne pas avoir
beaucoup de petrov fab ouais bah ouais
là bon heureusement j'arrive donc vous
intéressant le débat
c'est avec avec vlad ça manquait un peu
de paix 38e cache pas
je ne te cache pas avec don't cry ou
mental et on taille
devrait donc faux f5 c'est un coup un
peu plus moderne bon juste assez logique
tu te développe mais ce qu'on avait à
l'oeuvre de la part des nord pendant
des décennies s'était soif ou des 6,5 et
6,6 quoi êtes-vous au 7 et u fait qu'il
ses six plus tard mme ça ça non mais
mardi est
donc vrai faux f5 me souvent l'idée et
noir en fait ça va être de retirer le
cas l'irlande 10 6 pour changer votre
case blanche
et d'ailleurs nous le répertoire facile
la différence n'a pas eu le temps de
redescendre ont fait des trois des gages
à dégager avec ton qui avait une merde
et comme ça surtout quand tu fais preuve
c'est
oui
on ne te laisse pas installé sur la case
the 4
hour ont laissé qu'un tel quel intérêt
de laisser là parce que quand tu joues
c'est catherine un peu plus celle qui
tremblant ouais face à peu marre d'avoir
des ressources pour le défendre mais bon
je discutais ce qu'en fait visuellement
tu dis bah pourquoi j'ai perdu autant
avec les blancs est-ce que tu as peut
quasiment vide faire car élus
s'inquiètent du niveau baladant ouais
bah oui mais bon alors que nous
après nous on veut jouer une petite
finale labaki ah bah oui avec deux
échecs et où donc alireza doit dire non
je regarde bien la dame en d1 au chaud
en tout cas là il doit avoir une bonne
prépa parce que c'est pas que c'était
attendu 7,7 petrov un oui il a joué nash
dorff mais quand même avant le tournoi
la petrov c'est quelque chose que tu as
dû préparer sur préparer
en fait c'est heureusement la mode tu as
plusieurs joueurs qu'ils la jouent dans
la perte warba dépôt oui car on a joué
pendant longtemps on les joue plus trop
mais potentiellement duda cesser son
arme principale duda voilà déjà trois
avec principaux qui font et puis rapport
tu sais jamais ce qui peut de faire et
peut toujours dire s'il en vie on ignore
allemand il fait pas mais bon qui sait
radjabov serait complètement dans ses
cordes ne s'y fait pas
et les chinois ils adorent les petrov
donc en fait tu peux avoir foule petrov
donc
normalement non quoi parce que naka il
fait pas il fait berlinoise radjabov
aussi et digne qui fait quatre ou cinq
normales
et garonne à la joue plus trop mais
tu sais
avec des telles touquet réfléchi la
fille rousse non parce que si
aujourd'hui on n'a ni le milieu de jeu
ni l'ouverture
il va falloir faire une bonne partie
aujourd'hui on l'a pas rappelé mais à un
enjeu réel pour ali reza set gagné parce
qu'il a moins 1 et
enfin terminé gagner une partie du jeu
d'échecs quoi j'ai envie de dire me
tiens sinon débat philosophique dommage
j'ai envie d'en parler à vlad mais je
pense qu'il va apprécier froid qui donne
son avis est ce que tu penses que le
foot pièces blanches et fort que le foot
cases noires
généralement position de départ c'est
vraiment très fins bah oui
bruit très plus fort bas parce qu'ils
seront plus forts ils votent s'arrête et
on s'attacherait à pour les blancs
voient
même lassitude devant choisir qu'un des
deux ira le foot est roi quoi je
n'aurais jamais pensé qu'un tel comme
toi puisse avoir aujourd'hui je sais pas
en tout cas elle a dit que huit sur huit
c'était vraiment très important que chez
qui parce que 64 cases faut pas tourner
de plus c'est reyes y en a deux de plus
le cavalier est moins fort que le fou
fou prend trop de place irwin c'est
vraiment la taille idéale vraiment eu
beaucoup de tests au travers des siècles
pour
808 ouais ben là c'est très grave est
celui dit ça mais ne lui dit pas de
chance il ya plus dormir pendant deux
semaines
il va revenir vous savez j'étais en
france s'ils sont vraiment très con et
fabien les visages ce qui m'a dit
quelque chose de très intéressant le
foot case blanche pour être plus fort
que le foot cases noires
font beaucoup trop complexe non mais
t'as plein d'ouverture en fait
finalement atteint quand toutes les
espagnoles de 4,5 sa graisse anciens
comme les françaises ont battu il ya pas
débat les carreaux cannes non plus mais
quand tu fais des 4 mais même quand ils
jouent des quatre ans fait
plonger de taper la base soit 1 il va
venir en d3 de ses deux fers au 4 mai je
pense que tu lui demandes tu va le
mettre en pls un
ben moi ça m'a mis en place au 6 mai
mais du coup enfin répondre par la
quiche amant en top 16
mais c'est une idée va c'est pas lui non
plus en fait c'est sa peine
peut-être je sais plus quoi en prennent
à roscoff au qatar à ses cousines
peut-être amiens kuzmin pour un appareil
non mais bon il est pote avec la grève
ça va parler à l'arrêt par les ouïes
petit veau 3,1
et ouais c'est cool line c'est sûr que
c'est kouzmine ça peut être que kuzmin
en fait
ce que vous viendrez sympa kuzmin en
plus
j'espère qu'il n'est pas décédé
d'ailleurs il ya un cousine qui est
décédé mais je sais pas si c'est lui
c'est un homonyme ce cas de kuzmin en
fait je crois que c'est pas lui
vous n'êtes pas l'air de céder quand on
en parlait pas longtemps mais non mais
c'est pas du tout un truc auquel je vais
penser
qu'une fois qu'on me pose la question
comme exposé les arguments comme un
rejet aurait peut-être qu'il est plus
fort en fait c'est sûr que c'est kuzmin
en fait
bien de garde en effet non plus je sais
qu'il se fait super chier
bon fillon qui réfléchit c'est pas super
bon signe non d'habitude il veut
tellement bon qu'on dit ça va mal il
sait pas du tout si c'est pas ça fait 12
à 12 ja c'est son truc il faut être cinq
là je vois dans la liste des parties
l'a2 partir de l'union interne puis quoi
l'unac et markovic aucune coupe sommet
aura sûrement d'autres une groupe carsen
bas il s'est pas déjà cités ou contre
400 en mars donc
auquel un truc rapide sur internet mais
bon cela dit le pain
et cck et cavalli c3i sinon aussi avant
les coups tout un mail c4 jouable au 5e
jeu peu trop bien qu'ils avaient laissé
troyat pas ici
il ya très peu meilleur
et plus sûr faut des six en fait
bon écoute on va se dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'ouverture sarah pas mais que les
autres jours c'était le milieu je donc
là peut-être que mes jambes sont
cueillies firent mal son temps à les
raisins va être comme ça j'ai pas trop
vu avant mais je pense que je vais bien
oui c'était pas ouf mais il n'était pas
à l'aise répression c'est tout c'est
même content radjabov pareil est ce
qu'ils se seraient pas trop mis la
pression peut-être
non mais c'est sûrement pas évident de
gérer un premier candidat en fait
c'est un truc que j'ai jamais vu que je
n'aurais jamais donc je peux pas trop
dire mais ça attendra un peu à part par
rapport à tous les autres
je pense qu'ils essayent se rappelle une
variante
tadic connaît pas quoi
alors
grand mot mais j'ai peut-être s'y
connaît quatre coups et c'est tout non
mais connaître plus loin que ça c'est
sûr mais peut-être qui connaît à peine
pas vraiment bien fait avant enfin comme
carson a commencé c'était des matchs et
je sais que j'ai fait un match contre 1
rognon qu'il ait fini par perdre mais
très serrée
dans les formats tournoi tassé à nouveau
puis 2013 et il avait gagné mais ne
s'était pas la première fois que je les
conduis dans tout cas rdba qui fâche un
match ou alors j'ai pu lire un truc sur
sur twitter il sait pas que moi parce
que c'est aussi c'est un débat que
j'avais déjà annoncé mais des gars débat
qui fâchent et les gars sur twitter
qu'ils la chose suivante vu que le
championnat du monde est un match
pourquoi on qualifie les joueurs à
partir d'un tournoi où est la logique
mais en fait tu vois les deux formats
mal est donc bien mérité dit jean fait
que vu que le championnat du monde c'est
on veut savoir lesquels et le cal est le
meilleur en match puisqu'à la fin c'est
un match
pourquoi la phase de qualifications n'a
rien à voir avec la avec le gros lot il
ferait pas un tournoi champions du monde
alors oui voilà c'est ça c'était le truc
qui fâchent et c'est en fait qui disait
si à la fin il ya un match pour pour
donner le vainqueur
pourquoi pas faire que des matchs en
fait du coup parce que ce serait plus
logique de pas changé le fin ne pas
avoir deux formats différents sur la
qualification
serait pas choqué par aucun des deux
tournois de championnat du monde ou un
match champion du monde des matches des
candidats non mais c est ce qu un
tournant des candidats combine un match
championnat du monde il ya eu ce débat
sur twitter avec je sais pas quel point
c'est illogique c'est comme ça et
pourquoi pas
je reçois les matches tous les tournois
en fait on gère le challenger s'était
jamais un charlot quoi donc je passe pas
trop entre les gouttes oui c'est une
question c'est une question qui fâche et
un le temps n'attend donc tour à un rock
peut-être c4 manon
ou cavalli bébé doc et un coup jouable
personnes âgées qui a aidé 2 contre
sireau déjà ici je vois les parties
maxime confiant de ces quatre domaines
12 ans domine dias candidats
qui es b d2 ont toutes tailles la
position une dizaine de fois dans sa
pratique
et que des parties de lui en fait alors
est-ce qui connaît pas est ce qu'il
essaye de se rappeler la déjà depuis dix
minutes aujourd'hui alireza étonnant
quand même parce que là petrov même si
c'était pas obligé on s'y attendait
quand même c'est très possible que bat
encore plus une fois que tout ça c'est
que c'était la préparation de sur le
japon pendant des mois du coup
dit ouais bon cet homme prend une balle
parce que tout doit normalement ilic m
je sais pas il travaille mais il est
moins bien préparés que les autres
il connaît ses trucs mais une forme
moins profond et c est
ok autant faire une petrov
duda les forces et faiblesses des
faiblesses justement son répertoire qui
est pas encore complètement parfait
des forces et qu'il a beaucoup de
ressources
même quand il est pas bien il arrive à
se battre à trouver
calcule pas mal aussi bon joueur quoi
bien sûr grille ou qu'ils aient que
c'était un petit fritz way fritz jauzion
fritz trois repas donc oui mais bon mais
quand même un petit ordinateur
coup préparé avec des trucs ou non mais
il est moins bien préparés que les
autres
mais pourquoi pas enfin
lorsque même parce que bon je sais que
c'est mitton son
coach historique et c'est pas un joueur
de l'élite soient bon joueurs amis
tombent donc kebede deux jouets dont je
crois que c'est toujours plus ou moins
principal un
normand qui a aidé 6
me dont c'est pas la moitié d'un poisson
il avait quitté son tempo
ouais en fait
je dois dire que c'est pas évident de
comprendre pourquoi les blancs doivent
être mieux
mais en fait
c'est devenu un peu à la mode un de ses
deux précédents les françaises des
changes dans la berlinoise d'accepter
cette structure sa structure qui joue
beaucoup plus qu'avant ces aventures
vous voyez ça tu disait vrai bon ok j'ai
cherché autre chose et maintenant les
blancs essayé de presser un peu mais je
trouve vraiment pas simple d'y arriver
il faudra montrer précis alors ok t'as
un poil mieux développer tu as déjà la
tour sur la colonne a
du coup peut-être tu feras 1,45 mieux
que l'autre avocat du tunnel le chasser
c'est vraiment des micro détails
pays-bas révisant pour beaucoup d'entre
nous doivent prendre en otage avec
clément genre de trucs après tabou aucun
risque nantes a pas de risque mais des
noirs y jouent peu la paix trop fort
soit risqué 1 ils sont bons s'ils
veulent plus ou moins
on dit merci pour le résumé l'ond sur
youtube ben ouais après genre semble que
résumé express plaisent plus un fab
notamment sur le vote hier on sent que
les gens sont à suivre ouais que 56 % en
faveur du détail et
je me demande si on va permettre les
régimes et express sur la chaîne
principale d'ailleurs
finalement
ils sont beaux ces résumé express très
express non mais c'est votre tout le
sport ce qu'on désire tas d'infos voilà
away
du coup le résumé complet quatrième
chaîne qu en
bon rang général c'est qu'il va défendre
courant
très bon
à sortir le foot cases noires s'il prend
des trois tu prends de la dame tu peux
rebondir angers 3e 3 quelque part tu
peux aussi doubler les tours sur voilà
voir les autres juste pour voir pour
essayer de s'amuser à priori d'autres
d'autres petrov donc alors radjabov
entre ding
c'est quoi c'est une petite catalan
ouais
bon il est vraiment est bon ça va leur
répondra
fabriqueront pour la porte je crois que
ça joue ça un paria tanigaki carreau ah
ouais donc cette petrov oui mais c'est
pas nakakita joue là petrov une époque
il ajoute je vous dis n'a qu'à la joue
pas avec les normes et voit donc les
jeux qui nécessitent une touche y était
mais bon on n'est pas content ah bah
c'est sûr qu'ils s'approprient ya du
monde
normalement c'est à troyes qui est
proche et trois blessés qui sait si
c'est prendre des 5,2 me prendrait 5 oui
oui c'est ça ouais ouais l'époque et
nantes ok bon on verra et karena wihongi
j 4
très bien
ouais je sais quoi 3g 4 sur un sissoko
moi je penche déjà joué surnomment ses
centres bravo fabiano 1 mais réfléchit
déjà il connaît plus
non mais ce caillou cet open mind
est ce que tu retires ton cas des cats a
qui affiche en fait le seul énarque pour
qui vient de cette île va te bouffer et
remplacé l'autre
du coup de feu des rois vas tu restais
en 7 c et puis je retire est urgent et
si je te fais h4 et puis enfin il doit
réfléchir à ça ou alors tu t'en fous tu
fais foule 3 face à son problème hein
c'est pas mûr mais
merci à vallier pourquoi pas
ok et donc alireza passer son cours
tf1
donc pour revenir à vers 3
éventuellement g45
donc trois servent logique mais
qu'est-ce que ben oui je sais qu'il ya
17 le coût principal y en a qui jouent
ces 6 il a joué six ans c'est ici que
tout a déjà joué deux fois
au moins deux fois mais j'ai été deux
fois contre et 6 ping
ko tata steel l'an dernier et compte 40
scène on tire la scène en rapide sur
internet
que les autres joueurs qui ont joué ça
et qui sont pas mauvais outre d'houdain
ighirri en 2018 qui a fini le contrat
rognant les visites en 2019 contre un
nombre qui a fait nul niva et puis les
mecs à plus de 1600 rakhmanov dh
koné roues
ça descend c'est pas du tout très joué
quand on voit la
petite ligne mais comme je vous dis je
sais pas vraiment pourquoi on doit être
mieux clément et je comprends que vous
un peu pressés mais
un peu plus agréable quand même ouais
mais vraiment marginale quoi
pas duda a l'air d'être de cet avis a vu
qu il la répète
ouais
y'a que des nuls monde imagine dans la
base ouais alors après pendu en guipavas
train 2006 mais bon c'est juste qu'il
vaut mieux un échec puisque l'ouverture
warrick les chemins battus koné ou mais
pareil c'est qui les plus forts joueurs
d'échecs c'est quand même embêtant que
tu allais reza ait eu des prépas mire
sur des joueurs - cible quoi
s'ajoute avec les blancs c'est non mais
soit il a une idée à venir et je sais
pas il a le droit de réfléchir de
l'ouverture des jeux tout tempo mais ça
n'a pas l'air d'être le cas en fait
malheureusement
sinon bizarre pas enlever des quatre
premiers coups
sans fait la pléthore tu peux te
l'apprendre à l'idée de petrov bah oui
oui
oui fin de pas avoir d'idée pour bluff
mais faisait pauvres oui mais justement
c'est d'autant plus bluffant ce que la
même nous on est bluffé alors qu'on suit
toutes ces parties donc
en fait la sicile en train d'avoir une
prépa et qui fait ça c'est un beau bluff
non mais tu ne veux non mais c'est
possible ça existe aussi
tu crois tout aujourd'hui de réfléchir
en fait je connais beaucoup mieux que
d'autres jour le jour je devais n'en
sais rien
non mais si c'est un bluff c'est
magistral
tu vas pas là convaincu sur le boeuf eux
pensent pas du coup oui s'il bluffe il
me bat six cibles fc un beau bluff
la pleine tête de bluffeur
n'a pas le beau double double faire
mais justement ce serait d'autant plus
amorphe c'est un joueur de poker
justement femme marie
sara quoi bluffer complètement à part de
perdre du temps ben en fait ça peut être
pas mal à vrai dire kasparov le faisait
beaucoup ce que le mec du guce crois que
c'est pas très dangereux ce que tu fais
en fait une petit idée un peu faim
vraiment bien qu'ils voient le titre
good bye bye bye la clique au hasard et
tout d'un coup on fait de la merde en
fait
oui c'est que tu évalues - danger
vas-y mc12 tempo il faut soit très
vigilante est vraiment concentré à fond
et sinon tu peux dire ok bon ça va il
fait pas grand chose je connais mon truc
hop hop hop et petites imprécisions
ça peut un
fab ça peut way
back office j'y crois pas là non mais tu
y crois pas mais c'est possible tout est
possible
c'est un peu l'année s'était vu ce sens
de ma question c'est est ce que c'est
possible
mais je sais pas dans le
vent tennant 20 ouais mais la paire de
virevolter
ce sera un très très beau bluff là si
c'en est un fab c'est beau qu'on fait
comme au cyclisme en début d'étape quand
on vole avec sur leurs vélos annoncé pas
en fait si on le sent bien assis sur sa
selle ou pas quoi
penser qu'on peut pas savoir il
réfléchit donc j'aime pas trop son coup
de [ __ ] et je pense qu'ils
empruntaient
pioche un peu peut-être un peu trop
fêterait pas les autres jours et il
n'arrive pas en début d'étape
aujourd'hui
foly nedy lactique un peu je pense faire
mieux après c'est pas parce qu'il est en
queue de peloton après 25 kilomètres
qu'il est dans une mauvaise journée
fabien peut-être qui se laisse lentement
a mené par ses équipiers et qui
reviendra se mêler à la victoire finale
à partir du 125e 130e km on rappelle qui
aura une bosse à 20 kilomètres de
l'arrivée
c'est là que des gens souffrent
dangereux normalement c'est à ce moment
là donc c'est pas parce que tu étais
derrière en début d'étape que tu sera
forcément derrière au moment où les
cadors fab se discuteront s expliqueront
au sommet de cette petite côte de
première catégorie qui fait 4 km de sens
mais qui est vraiment casse pas de façon
naturelle sur les 800 derniers mètres
avec des pourcentages à 18 même 18
c'est souvent là que le vainqueur de la
5e étape du tour
s'échapper on le revoit plus ça va
peut-être du mal après à s'entendre
derrière mais
ça va bien l'avenir nous le dira
l'avenir le dira arrivée prévue à peu
près vers les 19h45 20h par les
organisateurs
ben y'a rien d'autre a du mal à 11
contre 10 ce que je peux te dire comment
on les mecs ont joué contre cette
opposition dé partie des tous meilleurs
je veux les coûts ouais on va bouger les
cours alors attends speech s en fout un
peu en partie normale sur un échiquier
ici pinko duda
kroeff quatre
bons fous prend des trois dames prend
des trois caïds et cette dame b3 tac le
pion qui a et b 6
à 4
l'artiste est baissée cadref tu pouvais
faire à saint denis at on constaté j'ai
vu cette partie c'est ou we can see as
bari le début on la commente avec
matthieu chedid aux cinq
salles et prend pions prends tu veux
dire aux 4
kg 3 l'homme prend très vite
après a priori savent-elles d'un truc où
il était peut-être un truc et que les
blancs oui c'est pas trop mais donc
voilà bon il doit mesurer quelque part
écrit noir il pourra pas répéter
exactement ça si c'est ça la partie
un an de vie dit pas inquiet at il dit
c'est son directeur sportif qui lui dit
30 dans l'oreillette
on me dit tu sais tu fais 4 aussi
élargie qui jettera un regard du coup si
on est qualifié 3 à un moment a indiqué
j'ai trouvé sur ce coup mais qui a été
trop intéressant jarre joué par un
rognon speech s est normalement la suite
il faut prendre des trois dames prend
des trois cavaliers à 6
je
passais pour violences et 7,6 sûrement
je vois pas trop ce qui va faire en b 4e
dire c'est trop trop trop débile qua
non à l'on s'attend à ça
- qui une petite nouveauté déjà mais bon
ok j'ai trois je pense qu'il va prendre
tu as joué tempo un dame prend des trois
énormes à longueuil à 6
et qui est 17 pourquoi se serait
mardi aime pas du tout mais pourquoi bah
je sais pas trop où peut-on pourquoi ce
récit concret système points ouais mais
j'étais sûr qu'il allait fermer
pourquoi c'est si mal qui a aidé cette
ire paroisse là ça sent pas bon du tout
j'y vais
un gros zéro 0,1 le bien de nos avants
0,35
on
lit des forces nouvelles qui a lancé
cette
bombe mardi
ils baissent même mal à 0,25 ah ouais
mais c'est plus tu vas laisser tourner
puis va tendre vers zéro 0,1 il propose
éventuellement b3 pour essayer de faire
ces quatre mois mais bon c'est assez
logique oui pourquoi pas qui n'a
déjà qu'une seule fois 22 au 24 ans
entre autres choses
avec arsenal gb 3 contre nous da et
daniel rickardsson duda on va t'y
connais très bien la position de là il
s'est pris deux fois est sûr b3 l'effet
tour vite les deux fois rockets
what else il propose sinon bah juste fou
des deux vraiment fait quoi fofi 4
bon il propose rien de temps hier
inquiétant inquiète en ce début de
partie pour pour le joueur français
d'origine iranienne
je pense qu'il va réfléchir
peut-être on peut retourner faire un
tour chez caruana voir reste peu sur la
plus fofolle un peu il a fait tout le
travail du bessin
c'est digne la photo
du coup on peut aller voir ding allez
allons voir ding
ok modding
bon sens voire compliquée il ya toutes
les pièces mais les noirs normalement
leur ai dit ça est de réaliser ces 5 e
pour l'étude et le centre
dans le temps soit pardon
et c'est qu'on a pas vu icaro ouais
alors c'est tout rade tient
aux questions d'une petite idée thouars
2 pourquoi
j'aime bien bas c'est sûrement déjà joué
en fait mais mais j'aime bien que
normalement sur ces prend des dames
prend des cinq tours a plus accès il
faut être quatre à taxer 7 mai faisait
des tours c'est 8 soit même des fois tu
veux te donner sa cinquième welz au
foyer eu beaucoup ont fait la dernière
nouvelle sauce à recy non non non
c'était dans un but 4-5 ans rien à voir
sinon c'était une berline 9e n'ont rien
à voir absolument rien à voir j'ai eu un
flash avec un fouet et quatre pouces et
7 mais oui ça absolument en avoir je
peux tchékistes aura deux juste pour
pure curiosité des troqué ses six
essais a déjà été jouée par le hb lui
même ok
je sais pas si casse parfait pas déjà
fait un truc comme ça peut-être contre
adams où
tu vois deux ans et camille peyrard 13
tours de
13 toit de la tour et un tour à tour de
taille et quelques parties le h les gens
en 2016
l'excès flèche joué quasiment champion
avait joué sa reach et que c'était n'est
pas guéri pas ici pas comme ça
lâche en khl
qui a annoncé sur twitter je crois avoir
commandé le kobe doin
lâchant quelques ya qu'a contractée le
kobe donc si vous avez vu la chambre
c'est ce qu'il écrivait ça nous tester
vous tester
ce rallye raisin bois tu peux pour le
moment mais il n'y a pas de
vraiment ballon
ça va peut-être venir
c'est que le début par ja partie de
karwan a quand même un mais mais c'est
vrai que d'habitude les les ouvertures
d'alireza sont très passionnante depuis
ses 4 premières journées c'est la
première fois où on est un peu ce sont
d'autres fins un peu sur notre faim vrai
mais bon peut-être qui on sera beaucoup
plus emballé par le milieu doit du coup
oui oui ça dans 10 propose à quatre ce
que c'est intéressant pour écoute
probable en petites prises des espaces
c'est un peu l'approché moderne là
d'aller pousser ses pions sur elle
quand je vous dit en fait moi je suis
pas trop inquiet la pression en général
j'ai vu maxime empressé un des
structures comme bruit non mais ils
savent et s'affairent les mac dégâts
forêt
donc c'est pour ça que l'on va mais
l'option 6 4 non tu peux pas les trois
c4 peut-être marbre
c'est ce que craint on peut regarder une
partie de terrain des compagnies
b300 duda donc c'est un rapide sur
internet mais rapide b3 l'effet tour
s'est vite tourné huit ans
ces quatre fois fuite on échange des
tours fou des deux auquel il est tour
jeudi m6
j'ai un peu les 15
h 4 way
down 17
ces cinq
cavaliers leucate
ok vous tout reprend qui prend ses 5 et
+ power madame c4 c4 il appartient aux
six tours à 20 b5
et aux caisses à jouer le nul
cela dit est ce qu'avant il était
comédien y aurait peut-être stade à
partir de duda sur ce truc c'est en mars
cette année
mais b3 j'aime pas mal enfin je crois je
trouve seulement un truc où tu essayes
de
seuils de fer ckt de prendre le centre
quoi
éventuellement c5 et jouer pour un fouet
fkt les cases noires
mois en fait ce qui m'inquiète là c'est
pas ça c'est que si tu es préparer tu
peux avoir une idée à avoir un truc
pénible par contre si tu connais pas du
tout là avec les blancs je sais pas
comment tu peux poser des problèmes à
quelqu'un très bien préparés après doit
être un peu des structures mou
mais souvent c'est corrélée à la pousser
les pions h en fait h 4 h 5 qui
m'atteint kf5 et des petits machins
comme ça un peu un peu pénible
complet
j'avais ouvrir la porte
revient pas d'une seconde
allez
allez reza
dans tous les cas quoiqu'il en soit ce
sera une excellente expérience 1 les
candidats
ne sont pas les résas pas réussi à jouer
son jeu jusqu'à maintenant
bah
c'est pas dur à 10,1 contre radjabov
idée c'est de mettre la pression mais
j'ai eu du répondant
contre rapporte
écoute c'est pas évident
très vite à rentrer en finale n'a qu'à y
laisser la pression hier c'était mon
pitié mais il a beaucoup voyagé avec
niveau
ce contrat les razzias sur internet a
plein de fouet la dernière partie en
date j'ai fait nul
c'était un title tuesday ou un truc
comme ça
fout des deux
ok donc là on quitte les parties top
niveau
mais pourquoi la priorité des live est
moins
je pense pas que je t'aime bon tempo
mais bon a priori que vous me touré 8
takam bien envie de faire non
d'abord ça pour être là et c'est cette
aussi
ouais non ca
possible mais non c'est pas une partie
super compliqué tactiquement et
stratégiquement peut-être y avoir des
détails il faudra être bon
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il peut pas la perdre
on sait jamais mais normalement dans we
géré par là qu'il prend pas de risque
non plus voilà exactement
cherchait déjà un truc
ou deux puisqu'il dit aujourd'hui
oui on se sont dits qu'ils essaient ça
va toujours 8
oui je ne reconnais pas le style de
fille roues pour l'instant comme si les
vins a pris un ascendant sur lui alors
qu'il n'a que 19 ans 1 mais le truc
c'est que c'est pas le même niveau de
jeu aux candidats ont assez particulier
quoi c'est dur en fait enfin ça joue en
face que ouais
en gros
sajoo et puis il ya d'autres choses à
jouer mais en plus les gars arrivent
super bien préparé mais n'est ce pas et
puis joue sur tes points faibles là
clairement alireza il y avait un peu
l'effet de surprise avant entre
guillemets là maintenant ils le
connaissent et ils le disent quand des
cajas arrive c'est petit à petit tu
penses avoir un peu des mecs qui l'ont
battu que si l'on fait un bien sûr et
puis voilà ça va pas empêcher de
progresser quand même deux mais même tu
ap ap
à 19 ans il était quasiment plus décisif
aujourd'hui
alors là il y aura mon bon mais ouais
ça qu au début tu dis c'est quoi cette
fusée au début et c'est isa mêmes visées
aucune idée de comment défendre
mais
moins décimé plus traire enfin qu'est ce
qu'il a gagné cette saison en ligue 1
non mais
voilà qu elle était quand même champions
mais l'équipe coupe du monde avec
l'équipe de france bon là avec le psg
effet huitièmes de finale rien tu vois
benzema en face mais bon j'ai juste a
dit foods effet mal coiffée mal à
saint-etienne
déjà contre le real bonté enfin il n'est
pas décisif dans les très grands matches
et marqué contre
les plus bas moins décisif jaf un
footix banon enfin il aya stockage
gers tuer des civils tués fin vous
regarde je serais allé aussi mais bon
bon bah voilà enfin géré moins décisif
quand même fin
il est excellent en ligue des champions
mais bon enfin j'arrive à calage 3 il
n'a toujours pas gagné ligue des
champions ces deux journées de débats
qui met genre de la table pour ce il n'a
jamais gagné quoi ouais mais des mecs
ben déjà ring benzema l'a gagné combien
quatre fois cette m5 un même 5
ouais bah oui ça va être dur en fait des
mecs qui est au real dans cette année
2010 ils ont bien rasé et ça fait parti
de choisir le bon club je sais pas
comment dire mais ici il a quand même
gagné un paquet de fois aussi il
ya une fois messi
pas 3 ou 4 je dirais je sais pas
tc sète et a priori c'est même le coup
préféré de l'ordre puisque tourne vite
pour des raisons qui m'échappent mais
n'y a plus qu'une parti c'est jacquel
contre malek des obscurs joueurs on sait
pas on connaît pas c'est pas par
correspondance à des vrais joueurs un
open à innsbruck en 2021
voit les bons je pense en juin coin
précis des faits kallio 5 qui vive si
cet art parti la queue entre les jambes
et l'aurait fait dame des sept tours à
huit et ça va très bien
touré fait vite que mieux
[Musique]
j le tchador en fait trieurs le chat
with complètement fou après
l'aube au moins tu as pu mettre un petit
peu d'ambiance mais ce que sinon déjà
qu'on a une petrov si on veut pas
trigger le chat
baverel a été très heureux et toi aussi
de casser saken quoi ah bah oui les
relais des recettes est quant à lui
c'était une tel crime que même ici il
fait beaucoup moins chaud depuis
j'ai cassé sa canne il a fait déjà fait
beaucoup de bien
ces sacs
et sacoches
rapprochement
[Rires]
il était complètement au dessus de
casser sa canne
oranges et cartes graphiques face et
chic
l'inflation les gens sont très heureux
de ces cas c'est ça calme
madame présent pour le titre à wimbledon
bas mais je pense je vais boycotter me
le donne moi ta natation ma tasse pas
content à la miss et gilles leroy là où
ma caisse sagan à l'ami de segi leroy et
puis après on ne sait plus quoi
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui a mis les vraies
paroles le bond
des gens qui n'ont pas l'arrêt fait mais
il faut regarder un petit peu twitch je
leur ai pas eues en temps normal comme
je fais grève bah ouais mais les belles
rêve quand même
donc
au départ
earth compte pas pour la tp en fin de
course et une exhibition
les mecs qui vont parce que gère dans
plein de tournois les gars ont diminué
il s'arrache pour essayer de passer un
tour de plus et gratter des points atp
qui seront utiles la question est
arrachée pour deux blessés peut-être pas
joué et tournera points après quoi donc
ça ira tu vas jouer mais je ne peux pas
donner ton à 100% donc je sais pas je
déplacerais enfin l'atp l'a fait bravo
et moi je vais pas sûr avec intérêt du
tout moi je rangerai résultat
ça va pas trop me
ip
ack1y tout un déchet qu'un qu'il n'ya
plus d'enjeu il n'ya pas qu'eux mais pas
dangereux a pas d'enjeu un
même un grand chelem au final tu vois
c'est pour dire en fait
on va voir ce qui va jouer là l'ordi
donne vraiment égale égal maintenant fou
des deux essais 7 alors qu'est-ce qui on
peut regarder ça plus en détail ce que
tours de 5 ou watch quatre
bons jeux se tourne un peu en montant en
profondeur mais
jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas la partie
la partie pour le moment là - moins
intéressante d'alireza jusqu'à
maintenant ça pourrait être très très
sec
aujourd'hui et ça pourrait être une
nulle sans aucune histoire beaucoup de
monde mardi l'envoi h 4 quand même mais
je pense qu'il faut faire
parce que sinon ils vont se mettre en
place et vont échanger sur la colonne il
y aura plus rien
poussant les prépas n'ai pas réfléchi
depuis 10 minutes à peut-être qu'il a
sorti une ligne tours à deux tours a de
la gueule c'est vrai
étonnant là pas d'ali reza aujourd'hui
étaient absolument parfait jusqu'à
maintenant ça a été même son point fort
jusque là que de belles prépa de la part
d' ali reza est aujourd'hui étonnant
contre la petrov larmes qui reste quand
même l'armé principale de duda contre 4
qu'il avait simplement rien il avait
fait comme une impasse un fab ouais
c'est étonnant
et surtout qu'il aurait pu faire re 4,5
pouces et quatre du coup s'il avait eu
vraiment pas regarder la petrov du tout
oui ce qu'il a joué ce fou ces 4 contre
l'epo qui
aurait pu décider de bifurquer il est
rentré trois mâts non là c'est bon tu
sais mais bon ça des trois coups de
l'ordi à l'avant je suis très étonné par
le coup que l'ordi donne et j'espère
enfin j'espère que c'est bah ouais
j'espère pour ma grosse sont des échecs
que cf 5e que tout elle jouera pas mais
f5 sa part est vraiment con mais mais
ils sont à mais tu sais que ça me
rappelle une hymne de la petrov que j'ai
joué contre je me suis préparé enfin
c'est une histoire un peu bizarre mais
un
je suis référé contre quesada
25,4 en fait il me joue un truc sur
l'app et raf
est malheureusement pour moi j'ai appris
19 coups par coeur mais j'ai déjà oublié
voilà juste contre sa ligne pour jouer
sur une partie est en fait un monde et
ajustait pts 5 f 4g 5 et je pense que la
partie c'est d'être nouveautés g100
atteint les nouveautés le truc juste à
retirer au 19e et je pense que cinq
coups après ils avaient faim il pouvait
déjà abandonné et c'était hyper fort par
georges despature et f5 africa fin c'est
une autre position 1 en gros je viens tu
ramènes truquant là et tout d'un coup tu
as tout qui se ramène
alors je prends tellement d' espaces que
tu enterres le fou et je comprends gomes
et a du mal à imaginer que cela puisse
se passer quoi passerait si ça passe ça
passera f5 numéro 1 de mon stockfisch
matoury 8 tempo
bon plus normal pour moi maintenant
c'est quatre peut-être
ouais mais n'aime pas trop du coup 3 8
10 et 4 c'est bien pour les blancs
comme celui là c'est vraiment des
détails je sais pas trop j'ai pas trop
le truc mais f1 avec l'autre idée
c'était avant d'en replanter le cahier
henri iv en fait non plus simple et
après peut-être à des
f-5 sais pas si mauvais non mais oui
mais avec 4,3 après aussi tu vois quand
on la tourne fuite f5 f4f 3 ça peut
aller 4 essayez omap4 fer s'était fait
au moins prétendre un avantage qui t'a
fait b 3
taureaux vite joué peut-être un peu vite
non quand même de la part de jean
christophe bas en fait ce qui est
probable c'est que c'était b trop te
fout des deux qui voit là bas qu'il a
déjà analysé à chaud café ch 1 et ses
quatre essais cet excès de raku enfin
j'ai une cessation méthode c'est un truc
de penser la police cherchait
bon mais fainéant quand même ouais c'est
pas une bonne chose
c'est le candidat ou cassé sa chaîne qui
sont partout quoi
peut-être que la chanson là devenir
mythique finalement vrai que ça va
beaucoup plus marcher que c'était très
bien passée et qu'il avait rien dit que
la fin du clip est horrible duo cassé sa
canne
en fils de se mettre complètement fou
ça se voit que ça va pas aller
syrien qui va aller bon après
après on
pas choquer mais bon ouais ouais
je pense pas que les gars de vitalis il
est vraiment mal pris enfin on prend que
c'est un gars qui était bleu qui est à
dire son truc grince pas méchant
ça tue trop tolérant aussi je ne sais
pas mais moi ça va pas choquer
ma fille tu sens bien avec ses 1
supporters ça s'est passé pas la
structure ou quoi
c'est juste ma maison hier c'est ça
non mais en fait je comprends c'est
juste qu'il a craqué en fait il était
bourré et beaucoup de gens en face de
lui passer mon interprétation 1 il a pas
réussi à chanter le truc il a vu que ça
faisait un bide total et s'est retrouvé
devant autant de personnes furent
invités fils il a voulu dire trucs sur
vitality pour essayer que les gens
fassent où il faut que je dise une
dinguerie pour sauver le truc est en
fait c'est en
fait je comprends tout à fait justement
de faire un bide énorme qui vont faut
que je sauve coiffard
mais voilà quoi je pense après j'ai pas
l'interprétation mais paraissait logique
presque y aura pas d'ouverture s'est lui
cassé sa tanière
master class de nagui par contre à la
fin qu'est ce que tu veux faire de toute
façon moi ça m'arrivait d'être à côté de
vlad et devoir récupérer des trucs
tiraillant matin tu continues
tu continues et puis voilà façon tu peux
rien faire d'autre a prêté bloqués
donc tour de huit coups de ces quatre
s'il a joué b3 pour pas faire ces cas tu
diras tu dis belle façon son temps de
réflexion quand même je le trouve
j'ai passé quatre noms mais je veux dire
par là qu il a réussi par h à lâcher ses
coups je sais pas je le sens - des
témoins
mais fait-on
déjà une heure de réflexion cazilhac
par des coups là je suis pas fière c'est
faisable appareil placé
sous le nom mais là on puisse vous dire
c'est très bien très fin mais juste en
fait impression sur des coûts logique et
metz caen fait tout ruitz et gagne un
coup très logique et après je maintiens
de fer b3 faire ces 4 enfin juste
remonté la séquence et pourquoi ça nous
paraît bizarre bon là tu joues b3 la
seule idée de b3 cc4 pour pouvoir
reprendre enfin tout un pan tutu des
champions il fait toujours 8 qui est pas
juste coût le plus logique et le plus
naturel de la position en fait si tu
fais passer 4 pourquoi tu as fait b3
entrevoit enfin si tu l'as fait pour
faire 1 4 fait à calmer non mais tu vois
pas comme si j'avais enfin genre t'as
dit ah tu dis b en fait
c'est probablement pas pourvu d'écaillé
fait 4 et justes dans tout ce tournoi à
chaque fois pour jouer des coups qui
dans la séquence sont évidents il
reprend 10 15 20 même trente minutes il
est pris pour damas 8 es fou prend à 3,2
fois trente minutes et je sais enfin
c'est pas quelque chose de normal en
fait
il a pas le bon flow comme dit vlad je
sais pas si c'est un mot qui se comprend
bien pour tout le monde
mais il y assez saccadée en fait
il le fait même est trop tard
après là c'est pas très pénalisant mais
tu es il a repris 6 minutes 30
du coup il met pas la pression à la
pendule et eux c'est le coup de doodle
qui m'intéresse
pas ce que je dis et le redis était un
peu
suspicieux avec le coutour évite sonnant
après c'est bien joué pour la peine
c'est pas vraiment une critique sur ce
coup précis c'est plus une impression
sur l'ensemble du tournoi
surtout qu à bucarest il faisait pas
vraiment ça
non mais tout à fait exact 11 positions
en europe deux coups il avait joué faux
et festif y
compris dany
à sa transpose
à la fille des world cup
rapide
bref si c'est ça oui c'était ça la
partie je peux te dire cavaliers 4 qui
est prend le cadre d'épreuves 14 24 24
dame prend 1,4 cavalli ou six noms il
fait feu contre autre chose
ça tape là est là il faut et 6 x 5
des 6 pouces et
3d cbcb 5
avec toi non
des fois 5 c'était peut-être pas le
couple non
non l'ordi réfection c5 mais ces cinq
c'est assez logique parce qu'en fait si
ces genres admettons cavale et b5 voilà
irak à triana turtle cavale et ses huit
mais en fait même si mille fois f400
sans chercher à grand chose ça ressemble
au système de londres hôte a bien fixé
ton pions bkt tu as bekkat à quatre
baies 5 et tu va taper sur les dames
avec le foin f4 c'est une horreur à
jouer
fois ici ces cinq cas veilleux can si le
corset carell et prend le cadre
d'épreuves 4.4 forcé tout reprend le
cadre d'un point 4 qui a valu six menace
cavale et prend ses cinq menace qui est
prend des 4 et là je regardais juste
titre qui donne tour d un donc ça c'est
la ligne vraiment principal cavaliers
prend des quatre ici est fou c'est 3 il
faut savoir ce que ça donne est ce
qu'après cavaliers problème trois dames
point f3 dams est fou prend un f6 forgé
projet prend est-ce que c'est assez ou
pas moi je prendrais les blancs quand
même quelque chose
aux faibles c'est au tour des filles
sont plus aléatoires les six dames un
match
h4 est ce que je voulais mais même hk
tour des huit mais même cette finale l'a
fait on des huit dames prend des huîtres
ok si ça c'est nul ça doit être mue en
fait ça
alors dit non au sud est d'alger quatre
échecs et d'amd 4control la colonne
pour essayer de blindés et peut-être
petit à petit faire un tour des 3 une
fois qu'il pleut mat du couloir c'est
quand même qu'un petit quelque chose et
c'est pas sûr que tout allait rentrer
dedans mais si tu veux pas rentrer là
dedans ça veut dire que tu as parfois f6
normalement cela des études et du marché
parce qu'il fait lui aussi il a fait
faux at this way il veut cette finale
c'est sûr que oui c'est en fait la
variante est quasi forcée
enfin 10 tiff à cette vitesse 1 il a
fait que guigne depuis la partie et
rentrer là dedans en force
mais faut faire avec les blancs alors
dans un petit avantage mais tant que ça
en fait
attaqué ça mais c'est un peu mieux enfin
un peu mieux ouais c'est des bouts de
chandelle
chantal
john
ouais hein
wemmel et rezaï connaît pas donc il doit
calculer c'est con parce que si jamais
une chance d'avoir davantage pour de
vrai bah tu peux vraiment l'attraper qua
non mais oui
s'ils avaient quelque chose de piégeage
qu'avec partent avec va y avoir un moyen
de le choper vrai
la voix de thierry en voie
d'adoption un doublé puisque murray
doit 22 ans aujourd'hui un poil plus
mais il est pas très vieux ray
125 tête j peu trop je vous dire
24 il
y en a ils nés en 98 24 individus qu'il
ya 24
jeunot contre hyper je n'aurais
en revanche la chance
aux petits pas
mais bon fil rouge qui jouent ces cinq
je pense ici
paraît logique hein il a tout fait
pouvoir après évidemment il doit
pondérer au projet pour peser le pour et
le contre sur cavaliers aux 4 et lorsque
ça donne la position qu'on a vu
à les uns
jeter un petit coup d'oeil chez i car où
aller
a réfléchi
pour à 2 free fuite
serait beau qui gagne cas aujourd'hui
car au dépôt faire me revient en tête il
ya une le tournoi sera incroyable en
fait
pourquoi tu travailles les échecs en
fait juste rim quoi
il est quand même incroyable cet homme
le h contre carlson n'empêche je serai
très marrant comme h m va pas très
longtemps pour les jeunes et non je suis
pas sûr qu'il dirait que ces feux ni à
la fin mais pour nous ce serait marrant
je pense qu'il arrêtait stream rixe
qu'il arrêterait de stream et quelques
mois pour préparer des trucs où il y à
réparer parce qu'en fait tu peux prendre
genre hyper cher si tu prépares pas
je sais pas est en place je les
candidats aussi fait perdre de l'argent
ouais mais c'est pas vrai peut-être un
peu mais pas beaucoup
imagine si en plus il va se préparer
quoi lui conseiller de plusieurs
millions par an c'est un peu abuser ça
passe ça autant autant écart où il ya
plein de trucs que j'aime bien autant ça
ou c'est un peu abusé
quand même sur les trucs caritatives du
coup franc des pourcentages messaoud en
bas il n'ya pas que l'argent dans la vie
quoi
même méthode a dit que là où candidat il
perdait de l'argent j'ai pourtant
vraiment c'est juste pour faire simple
et jean est pour mais bon enfin on va
dire si un oeil hamas de côté que jamais
un chèque à rousset a bien un truc que
j'aime pas trop apprécié pas s'ils se
donnent une image si c'est vrai mais
après du coup moi je pensais qu'ils
donner une image mais si le truc de se
faire du fric sur du caritatif est vrai
parce que c'est pas sûr c'est qu'il est
vraiment comme ça et ça j'aime pas trop
quoi
mais à
mai mais moi je sais pas j'ai du mal à
penser qu'il soit premier degré mais bon
ça ou pas tout le temps quoi pas tout le
temps mais non à un moment donné
tout cas voilà bah écoute il va tenter à
tenter un truc je sais pas
elles sont toujours à deux
ok les autres partis juste pour
juste pour voir ouais
bien non
enfin il y avait en fait qu'à ibb et 3
d'amd de man en hockey
non mais andrieu des partis qui joue
aussi intéressant parce que c'est risqué
en fait j'ai un truc comme ça qu'on les
reconnaît
donc ok on se sera une partie qui va
être intéressante celle là et radjabov
sans un truc à peu près ya deux centres
tu sens qu'il explose comme prévu
trois de ses cinq d'ailleurs ses défauts
des cinq dames de la part des petits
détails avec la casse et 6 un peu
affaibli te rentrer un jour un petit
machin mais normalement
je serai pas trop inquiet pour boarding
quoi
se diriger vers une petite nul
alireza ça réfléchit encore
bakiev jolie candy alors je crois pas
mais d'aller jouer les prix match pour
la qualif dans une fois contre kamski je
sais pas comment c'était plus l'époque
des matches
une autre époque la nôtre en 2007 par là
12h08 je sais pas par là
c'est très excitant pour perdre ou
drôles mais moi je trouve qu'il ait pas
de faim mais il n'est pas dedans je
trouve en dehors des ouvertures je
trouve qu'il n'est pas dedans
ah ouais
femmes tissu
ça je le truc rouge bizarre
[Rires]
c'est un joueur de réserve bonne
question je ne crois pas je me suis posé
la question hier qui se passe que c'est
un cap qu'ovide en fait
batum le bobeur forfait peut-être mais
j'espère ouais
bah comptable avait été forfait à 4,62
je crois que juste mais qui je compte
elle jouait pas quoi mais marque un
point et puis voilà
je suis partie gagnée 2 nuls pour un
temps comme celui-là je pencherai sur du
25 % de gain et 75% nullement
globalement
juste comme ça pourra regarder à la fin
ouais ouais ouais ouais à peu près je
dirais ça aussi je n'en peux plus
puisqu'après ya les warm up et warm up
boys qui peuvent arriver ouais envoyer
des points quoi
après il ya les déprimes boys peuvent
faire nul vite pourquoi s'embêter quand
ils sont hors course
on a fait le petit récap avait pas
encore assez peu faire le résumé de
l'ouverture
oui oui oui il faut le faire mais
attention
ouais allez on attend le coup de fil ou
parce que ces cinq
résidents nathan un coup de fuir au
travail qui aujourd'hui se passe
vraiment rien bah en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que l'on est déjà une belle
heure de jeu
twitter jack huawei est en fait c'est
une position que jude a déjà eu dans sa
pratique bien non et donc
pour l'instant rien de nouveau quoi fait
juste vrai plus d'enjeu tembo on ferait
15h04 serait pareil en fait ah ouais là
réellement ouais donc bon pour ça que je
sais pas je sais pas trop quoi dire plus
sans fin
bonjour
donc mettre les pendules visibles elles
sont visibles quand tu te balades
contées dans la salle tu vois après
l'afrique par rapport à la camelle un
peu loin face au maître des trucs très
gros soit mettre un petit temps du
numérique au mur serait passé compliqué
affectivement c'est simple mais bon
peut-être dans les années 2040 2050 avec
les nouvelles la technologie
ou sous la table ouais ou de ça pour
être devant simplement
bah oui ton chez vachement bien ouais
ouais mais c'est trop complexe fab et
aura un petit truc blanc pour recevront
des
prix sans l'aura jamais trop complexe
désolé
il y aurait de quoi faire
c'est devant les joueurs les joueurs
voient fumée mais face à peut être sur
la pendule est affichée devant
former la pendule tu la gardes faunes et
que vous appuyez mais
[Musique]
tu mets en plus devant une petite télé
quoi petit écran
ce serait bien en vrai bah oui bah ouais
surtout pour les gammes en fait quand
tous les tournois personnes regardent
trop vous voulez bien bon là ça rien
quoi
mais la paroisse avec sa voix un petit
plus
pour être juste la cam en grande
d'autres membres de vue du coût et non à
la pendule on en a les infos mais non
c'est vrai c'est une excellente idée
bravo le chat
bien mieux plutôt ce qui pour organiser
le chat
après c'est pas très difficile non plus
mais détrompe toi
très bonne idée
après l'aller réserve faux qui lâche ses
coups entre guillemets dans les parties
à bien ce que tu finisses deuxième
huitième des candidats ça change
absolument rien qu'une place winner
takes it all alors peut-être pas
celui-là
[Rires]
mais ben oui mais de toute façon on fait
aller faut lâcher ses coups là il lâche
pas ses coûts
tu vas regarde mehdorn ouais je sais pas
il n'est pas utile
il est très très très très très très
très très très très très bien préparé
mais dans le jeu dans le milieu de jeu
pour le moment il est il est loin de son
meilleur niveau
est ce que c'est parce qu'il est fatigué
par la préparation il est quand même
jeune et c'est pas facile à gérer est ce
que c'est parce qu'il s'est mis trop de
pression est ce que c'est parce qu'il
était en pleine bourre et finalement il
n'est pas aussi fort que ce qu'on tourne
en surrégime un peu et que et que voilà
il faut plutôt à 27 63 28 qui est déjà
énorme à son âge est ce que voilà il ya
ben on sait pas en fait
ce qui peut encore aider les candidats
bowie n'y a rien de fait mais bon il est
pas trop bien parti ça c'est sûr
mais as raismes 10 parties on n'a joué
que 4 donc tu viennes deux parties
d'affilée t'es pas trop mal quoi mais
bon déjà font gagner une on va gagner 2
à fils
fatigué par l'espagnol s'est pas la
révision de tout verte
n'empêche c'est vrai alors hors troll ça
peut avoir sa un impact sur la carrière
des jeunes joueurs des espagnols la
première fois qu'ils ont une copine non
mais son sens à absolument hors trop là
et or toujours su ça peut réellement
avoir un impact en fait
un coup ou même à la tête à ça va
peut-être tu découvres d'autres plaisirs
de la vie est
un fait ça c'est c'est possible la fée
torah d un centre hall c'est des choses
qui arrivent
et tu peux avoir une une période après
cent après là cela ne nous regarde pas
va bien
le second de caruana il me semble mais
c'est quelque chose de juste connu en
fait globalement à cet âge là il peut y
avoir un petit
passage à vide
tout à fait compréhensible
c
était magnifique ce sketch quels
intérêts protégés le pion des cadres
dans la variante qu'on a montré un petit
peu plus tôt des clous
laisse les noirs débrouille à trouver un
coup genre tu fais dame 17 pour les
détours tu as peut-être dû kallio cinq
tarifs dessus
après mon ordi pour surprendre pourquoi
j'ai 6 je sais pas mais ne mange pas
très envie de faire mais moi je vois
trop embêté à bien bouger mes pièces
mais
on se fait ce petit récap femme allait
gérer cap en une minute alors attend
enfin mettre le bon
le bon échiquier donc fait un petit
récap express en minutes de la partie
d'al irisé affirme jack contre
jean-christophe duda ali reza qui a
absolument besoin de reprendre confiance
et de gagner aujourd'hui après sa
défaite de la veille contre nepomniachi
qui envoie e4 e5 de la part de duda pas
une surprise et quand même c'est pas le
coup qu'il avait choisi dans son bain
jusqu'à maintenant fab nombre il avait
joué la nage dorff et donc là il va
plutôt tourné vers la petrov donc être
ok f6 une ouverture très solide parce
que symétrique on va le voir traqué
prend le cadre des quatre des cinq c'est
une structure bathymétriques fou détroit
d'alireza fouet f5 de duda qui va
vouloir échanger les fougasses blanche
par la suite c'est bon fout des blancs
petit rock foo aux sept tours un petit
rock qui a et b d2 qui a aidé 6 donc
voilà on se profile vers cet échange des
fous de cases blanches qui a validé fin
un petit coup de ses six qui va
renforcer le centre des noirs qui avait
allégé trois attaques le fief 5 donc
provoque les changes comprend des trois
dames prend des trois développement du
cavalière à assise qui pourra ensuite se
rapatrier vers le centre en ces sept
fous des deux joué car lycées 7b trois
tours 8
ces quatre fois m6 est en fait jusqu'à
présent suivait une partie que woods
avait déjà
jouer lui même avec les noirs c'est ça
je fous à 5 ici le coup intéressant a pu
être ses cinq peut-être avec une
position peut-être légèrement favorable
aux le blanc mais dur à dire à quel
point est allé hasard choisi de jouer un
tour à des 1re en forçant son centre est
donc on en est là
légère pression mais assez égal petit
bémol quand même cote alireza déjà 57
minutes 2-2 dépensé contre seulement 14
côté jean-christophe et on espère qu'ils
réussissent à faire la différence dans
le milieu de jeu
on dire plus bah non c'est à dire le
coût de duda va être très important
parce que bon leur dis tant vers des 0-0
avec les plein exercice faut tout
reprendre
mais je sais pas j'ai ici ça me semble
pas bon c'est pas si débile un tu
cloisonne le kg 3 davy d'écaillage
saints qui ont peut-être tomber testtube
état d'âme ou quoi les cases noires
façon tu contrôles talent production de
kyoto
vous êtes les mêmes maps et des résumés
on essaye de nous trois un petit peu
quand même de rebondir sur le troll
terrible côté chat way s'est rien passé
en fait un jusqu'à maintenant parce que
comme le disait femmes on pourrait
quasiment à cette position après un
quart un petit quart d'heure de jeu et
pedro
ceux qui sont arrivés à césar sont ceux
qui sont arrivés au bon moment partout
on commence la partie commence
alors dit il fait au printemps prend un
g6 et s'en fout il fait rien en prennent
genre sofica trafic et 18 ans fille
découche je comprends pas mais en fait
je dis que cet amour solide qui se passe
et ça je crois qu'il vaut 8 il s'en fout
là de mettre l'autre en 26
à 6 un logis
80 trains autres clients c'est cette
night eux jouent sur le web attaque un
peu des quatre alors farias un jour qui
n'est pas inquiet mais en plus il ya des
f-5 les bars ont attaqué très nombreux
comme ça devrait aller quand même mais
j'ai l'ensemble sauf un peu le savoir
t'as que tu peux juste un fait que les
noirs rester normalement une relation
intense qui c'est un annoncé à
travailler en profondeur un peu au
dessus - ouais après le truc c'est
contre ce qu'ils ont dit dany c'est ça
on m'avait dit il avait joué un peu avec
des français mais français b5 pour que
la casse des cinq forte et peut-être
qu'on savait pas trop marché va vouloir
se faire marcher le truc je sais
peut-être pas idiot mais a priori ce
serait un peu moins fort que de faire ça
parce que c'est la position normale de
numéro 1 de de stockage chaque fiche way
du poisson
quelle profondeur bosse au départ je
regarde c'est le fait remonter vers 30
c'est déjà pas mal pendant une idée quoi
très bien vu
la connais pas au moins
il est un peu clic au hasard oui mais
oui c'est pas un mauvais clic en soit
je suis pas trop la scène des échecs
français qui menace directe furent ou
celles à venir français bat c ouais
enfin il était avant le début du tournoi
autrement dit un numéro trois mondial et
il a il a 19 ans donc très clairement
aurait même l'avenir de chèques mondiaux
quoi qu'il en soit l'équivalent de wigan
qui fit ce dernier écrit enfin peu
importe c'est le jeu le plus talentueux
et qui offre pour le moment des
meilleures garanties après ça veut pas
dire qu'il sera pas rattrapé par
d'autres
mais oui
je veux que carlson à son âge et à peu
près pareil
va peut-être il a plus des lots mais
après c'est difficile de comparer
carl von linné quoi en 90
en 2009
des deux forces armées carl ça ne l'est
pas car le sann oui il était dans un
creux générationnel vrai trou dans un
entre deux quads avait des gars qui
vieillissent ouais c'est sarah mika dans
tout ça qui est à rognan aurait pu
peut-être être le successeur et carson
était trop fort trop vite
carlos alcaraz des échecs carrément elle
le faisait sans retenue
sans qu'on sache si carlos alcaraz sur
un jour numéro mondial non ils hall jeu
pour mais pareil on sait parfaitement
après gerica alcaraz il a un tout petit
peu plus
de
deux gros résultats même s'ils ont déjà
mais il ya aussi beaucoup plus de
tournois de tennis que tournoi d'échecs
de regagner masters 1000 c'est dur ouais
mais bon faut marquer un grand suisse
alireza
oui mais en fait ces
attentats pas d énorme poisson
genre c'est comme ça la droite et
interdisait les 10 millions de jobs
alors c'est déjà dur de gagner en fait
mais je veux dire comme caruana iv mvl
du monde ou en suisse
j'essaie de voir ce que je peux pour
comparer 20 ouais c'est pas si c'est pas
comparable en fait
en vrai
dell kace déjà carte grand chelem
australie et pas mal joué je crois
mais bon c'est équivalent pourra jamais
savoir exactement
c'est que sa pente est un tout petit peu
plus de temps ok tout de quoi arriver
s'il faut peut-être un peu plus de temps
aux échecs en fait tu dure plus
longtemps qu'au tennis tu peut durer
plus longtemps qu'au tennis il faut
peut-être un peu plus de temps pour y
arriver aussi
ce soit des joueurs vraiment super
jeunes aux échecs dominant y en a pas eu
massin or il faut au moins 20 en multi
c'est dur aussi très jeune fait ce qui a
fait nadal gagne roland très jeunes ou
de change ou sage quasiment jamais en
fait ouais mais ça arrive alors oui mais
c'est un grand chelem échec
c'est en fait tu as besoin physiquement
ça doit être là quoi je pense c'est
vraiment dur ans et aux échecs à part
carl scène jean luc hees pourra fêter
les rois du monde à 22 ans ouais mais
ces deux joueurs en 40 cent cinquante
ans quand même c'est comme ils ont duré
c'était dur les déboulonner mais je sais
mais bon au tennis etc à un peu plus
fréquents
soit tennis masculin ou féminin
d'ailleurs mais aussi des filles qui
arrivent parfois gênant c'est plus au
féminin en fait dans un pays soumis nice
a gagné à 15 ans ou 16 ans alors qu aux
échecs
mais tu peux durer plus longtemps aux
échecs par contre en contrepartie
quant à la quarantaine mais regarde un
mec comme à nantes à cinquante deux
anciens joueurs de tennis parfait dur
mais il sera plus changeant du monde oui
mais j'imagine un joueur top 20 mondial
à cinquante deux ans au tennis
rogers thuram et y associe impossible
quoi donc
déjà que tu peux quand même durée
riga
faire en fait que nico donc je pense
qu'il sera sur le twitter des vrais
twitter facile on va pas refaire toutes
les 10 minutes le récap quoi
ce que tu es joueur d'échecs ont
plusieurs nationalités leurs sacs aux
échecs en emmenant mais j'en avais parlé
dans un tournoi quand tu prends le top
10 mondial ils ont tous changé de
nationalité
enfin tous j'exagère mais il ya plus de
joueurs qui changent de nationalité qui
ne changent pas or pour le tas d'armes
saint amand dignement caruana wi fi
route jaoui des pauvres dont jouit
s'ouvrir à port louis mv elles n'ont ni
la gamme mais guérit oui mais non vous
voyez donc mais même n'a qu'à oui et non
ça y est née au japon il joue pour les
étoilés il j'ai trois ans enfin un
moment tu vas tu prenais ma médard dire
non en amenant dans une pièce vide ou
danon et kirby wii g-shock non non et
non andry qu'ils n'ont tous peuvent non
oui non et non médias dans les dix
premiers t'as qu'à roanne à fuir ou de
ja aronian saut à 5 rapporte 5 sur 10
qui ont changé nationalité c'est rare
quand même jeu spore août à cinq joueurs
sur dix qui ont changé de nationalité
adultes c'est un truc très mal fait aux
échecs c'est je crois une rencontre mais
en fait mais bon c'est comme ça
je suis pas au moins là pour le foot ils
sont cohérents c'est que quand tu as
joué avec une sélection c'est fini tu
vas pas jouer avec toutes les sélections
que tu veux comme c'était déclame quoi
edel au plus offrant comme ça t'arrange
donc
pourquoi
pourquoi ils changent pour l'argent a
généralement l'argent oui on leur offre
des trucs
disons le plus surprenant pour moi dans
toute la liste ça rognon ouais
parce que les autres je peux comprendre
leur caruana bon il est allé aux
américains déjà de naissance à ses
dépens et il a vécu jeunes à miami après
intel en italie il a joué un peu et qui
était une quantité petit et puis après
c'est notre top joueur il a choisi son
monopole mais je pense qu'ils étaient
binational dès la naissance en fait
parce qu'elle est de ses parents bon
après cela dit il a déjà joué avec
l'italie donc vous dis moi dans ma
vision des choses tu as choisis ta
sélection tu regardes abîmée bon la
garde lui je peux entendre
mais je rapporte qui est juste on voit
et qu'ils décident à tient en fait je
roumains parce qu'un mécène pas saine
unibet ou chez peugeot qui donne du fric
à il refait son bep 5-1 donc fait des
français donc il n'a pas fait le plein
exercice et va faire baisser quasi sûr
mais ok c'est sûrement un plan qu'il a
étudié avec le setup qui a six qui
essaient 7 et il sait que ça va alors
l'ordi a l'air assez content j'ai
regardé le mien ce qu'il en dit
en plus s'il doit être confiant parce
qu'ils annulent l'intérêt du coup tout
raté un jeu qui prend enfin qu'il a fait
bouger deux fois à rené dit que c'est
parce que son gouvernement lui donnait
pas les moyens promis ouais mais bon
est-ce que tous les français des ménages
s'est pas laissée à chaque fois que on
n'est pas content du système fiscal d'un
pays ou qu on déménage
mais j'attends enfin je sais pas je
connais pas exactement celle rognant
mais que c'était un peu une idole
nationale là bas on ne peut pas dire
c'est un mec qu'on lui demande et
laisser les échecs ski est un sport
national est ok alors peut-être qui peut
ainsi pas peut-être c'est sûr il faut
pas lui promettre les mêmes moyens que
signe que le fils peux lui promettre
mais
j'étais surpris je pensais qu'ils
étaient très attachés quoi ça je veux
dire alors après est ce que dans les
échecs oui est ce que t'as pas
l'impression que dans les sports
individuels l'argent et pas finalement
vraiment roi on peut s'attendre à ces
systèmes dans le sport quand même
généralement je sais pas
quand même moins gros mais je suis
d'accord avec toi tu pars moi je suis
surpris que ce soit possible de le faire
en fait
alireza réussi à changer de nationalité
pour d'autres raisons
bah disons ça qu'il ya un côté un peu
embêtant quand tu joues pour l'iran
c'est que tu peux pas jouer contre des
joueurs israéliens quoi illustre la
manière na waie non c'est vraiment un
vrai c'est un vrai problème
donc si shrek ou candidates un jeu pas
guelph on le sait pas qui se fait déjà
deux bulles quoi et
[Musique]
c'est embêtant
et nous on a eu le cas aussi au top 16
avec par ama qui a joué avec clichy les
deux dernières rondes et arrondi sur le
compte de bischwiller qui a rothstein
dans l'effectif donc dû prévenir le
capitaine bas qui est très bon on va
mettre en fuite voit donc de quoi tu
veux dire tu m c'est vrai je suis va
quitter failli voir un petit rappel teva
dit on mais apparemment il leva pilée
pas mis à part à eelv à peine bien
et donc du coup oui bah ouais qui ça va
il va pas me rothstein bon pour laisser
jouer quoi il est pas qui tu aurais dû
il aurait pu faire un monsieur au
cerveau
c'est pas de bol
[Rires]
est donc
bon khawaja ce truc là un peu pénible
pourquoi
c'est que les gens n'aiment pas leur mot
à dire que même si eux ils sont dégoûtés
si jamais mis à tirer en disant ça très
très mal
non ils ont vraiment pas et nous n'avons
pas le choix on peut leur dire
mais ça aurait été beau que bikey wii ne
t'inquiète pas ça bien se passer
donc oui rezaï avait le cas de figure
est joint un tournoi je crois green car
je trouve quoi à en allemagne donc je
sais pas il ya deux trois ans
trois rondes de il joue une joueuse
israélienne des forfaits vrai
wayne dont ils n'ont pas le choix et
donc c'est assez particulier donc la
raison du changement d'ali reza ce qu'on
prend à la pour la peine ce serait
compréhensible
b 5 mars qui joue ce qui prend au projet
france qu'il faut prendre
je pense tu prends du pur non
alors dit il faut à 5 le comprendre mais
peut-être pas une voie royale vers des
cinq dont tu fais casser ces quatre je
pense c'est cette dame c'est
7,4 peut-être pas comme ça et ben je
sais pas trop je sais pas ce que ça peut
me salir un pro non
franchement duda il joue assez vite
pour que la france je crois qu'il ya pas
de grandes raisons c'est juste que
l'opportunité que
what lies l'ancien président français a
pu faciliter aussi des choses aussi
d'être bons rapports avec
avec cette partie du monde
et voilà chartres a pu l'accueillir à
que c'était et c'est quoi mais je pense
pas qu'il y ait eu des attaches partie
avec la france a pu être l'espagne soit
les états unis ça aurait pu être
ailleurs à la base comme annoncé la
france
pourquoi pas au final bah oui pourquoi
je crois que même historiquement la
france et l'iran d'assez devra avoir des
bons rapports
on ferait revivre en france nos mains il
ya pile on fait venir toute sa famille
est venue et toute la famille et où il a
eu une autorisation accélérée tout fait
beaucoup de choses de faites
green sans un seul pour
magnifique
il parle français je crois pas enfin je
sais qu'à chaque fois on me dit qu'il
parle français à chaque fois que je
l'entends que j'ai il parle pas français
donc je pense pas qu'il parle français
par les points on va dire à l'imparfait
parlait pas français tati presse people
tête je sais pas
son frère parfois oui mais enfin gers
c'est lui là bas
c'est un très bon mais un cousin qui
valent très bien tout ça
je pense qu'il est plus à l'aise en
anglais en tout cas
donc des 5 c b
on verra ce qu'il va nous jouer
ouais bon c'est une position
intéressante parce qu'il ya un pion
passé centrale isolé aussi
les noirs ils ont un deux contre un et
l'âme donc chacun poirson son mot à dire
pour les finales éventuellement
réception des serait bien un peu
d'avancé quoi
interview dans l'équipe ouais en fait je
seulement les plaintes chauny ce qui
parle français et deux trois fois je
vais parler de tournoi j'ai envoyé
passait bien je sais pas c'est bah je
suis là après finir d'europe non ils
parlaient pas son passé qui équipe de
france il est vrai nom yves habitants il
ya six mois et enfin un peu plus à dix
huit mois selon lui par l'anglais vers
le français je sais face le jour au jour
entendu une interview de lui en français
tu pourras dire il parle français mais
sinon je
ne bluffe pas retenu jusqu'à preuve du
contraire j'y crois pas donc j'ai pas
entendu franc parler français couramment
chat qui parle comme llena par exemple
ma femme elle parle très bien français
maintenant mais ça a pris du temps un
empêche comme flad comme va de la vie
parle bien aux français non mais très
bien en plus il fait des jeux de mots ça
c'est très dur ouais je fais des jeux de
mots d'une langue ce que
c'est bon quoi
basile en équipe jusque ses parents par
le bien et lui pas encore ça paraît plus
aux machines et en live id
en string devant 10 15 me citer timide
ça fait peur de parler ouais super bien
nous on est français on parle français
serait construit mon parfum ont réussi
quoi je parlais anglais j'ai c'est vrai
quoi non mais je sais pas mais je vois
pas pourquoi c'est grave en fait un tas
le droit de pas parler français ou
d'enfin bon je ne comprends jamais le
problème à gérer ensemble quand tu dis
oui moi il parle pas encore français
fayat quad grave
ici par bombay par le pay par le parfum
n'y a rien il ya aucune gravité en fait
pas le droit de ne pas parler français
quand même
si je voulais que je parlerai je peux
parler russe
basée parle très bien français
genre tu as l'impression que vous non il
faut surtout dire qu'il parlait bien
français bombe et peut-être qu'ils
parlent d'ailleurs maintenant on n'en
sait rien en fait ce que donne ce qu'on
disait il ya quelques mois mais ça peut
aller très très vite en fait il peut ya
ça peut faire un déclic
la démarche un peu par déclic efa tu
parles pas et tout d'un coup en fait tu
parles
genre en l'espace de deux mois tu peux
faire un progrès de dingue non mais je
redis maria
il a fait quoi six ou sept saisons psg
au
football au foot oui
[Musique]
normalement caisse et 4 ici mais donc x
5 logique car il veut pas voir ce qui
allait venir s'installer en d5 serait
pénible ça bloquera pions pas céder et
cédera avancé b4 et machin c'est assez
logique ce soit
5,28 lice pour acquérir la société
française doit passer un test de langue
alors non vlad nous a dit la dernière
fois parce que je vais demander du coup
en live et lui l'a eu comme ali reza la
nationalité en tant que sportif de haut
niveau et en tant que sportif de haut
niveau là nous a dit en tout cas à
l'épaule oui la dre tu n'as pas besoin
d'examens de langue donc en fait il n'a
pas besoin de parler enfin
façon mais elle est là en fait sur le
jeu il est vraiment passé parce que
sportif denis aussi pouvait peut-être
prétendre être champion du monde un jour
et c'est ça et vous n'avez pas besoin de
voir les français en fait bon ben voilà
enfin donc on va pas nous emmerder avec
ça
c'est comme ça enfin et c'est pas grave
enfin et vlad a pas eu d'examen où il
m'a dit
dommage
c'est un sport les sportifs pros c'est
autre chose donc
mais voilà après il était francophile
mais de base de base serait
l'échec qu'il adorait genre et navo ou
quoi ouais et puis la littérature
française surtout mes chansons
françaises de vieille dame est morte à
souffrir
[Musique]
après il faut dire que les russes
globalement sons sont très francophile
joe dassin
ouais
sir préfère
aller il faut lui faire au
très heureux quoi
quatre reprises
m.medvedev celle inverse d'ailleurs le
joueur de tennis ea se piler du coulis
les russes mais ils se parlent en
français sur le courant oui ni celle
inverse en fait lui l'est pas il
représente pas la france mais vit en
france depuis jeunes et ils parlent
français ils se parlent français en fait
la nationalité alors c'est long et moi
je n'ai pas fait parce que tu peux pas
avoir la double quand tu deviens russe
là
où tu pouvais pas là encore
info à 5 et 6 et 4 ans a toutefois sa
vague et ses gants seront assez logique
perso
cette dame c'est cette ça doit être les
coups après je sais pas qui veille aux 4
ou quoi d'autre mais quelques attardés h
57 j'aime bien j'aime bien aller vers
l'avant alors dit quoi et abc soit mon
salaire quand même fab
ça a l'air d'être sarah la ligne genre
çà çà çà çà un turban décision fulham
est à la sarre où il faut pas le prendre
même si on va avoir et ce qu'il fait il
a fait cas ici comme pour moi ça
ressemble à nulle rapide
j'ai lu des infos que oui en fait qu'il
ya remédié qui qui empêcherait la vente
en étant désagréable et en faisant des
siennes encore une fois et là vraiment
s'il fait ça ça va mal se passer
mais bon
moi j'espère qu'il aura la vente
ardemment
du coup si c'est ça en fera peut-être le
peut-être le
la speed analyse de la partie de fear
budget puis on en prendra une deuxième
détaillé parce que là il ya merouana
peut-être lieu 4 on va voir faut encore
là j'attendais ça c'est top quoi enfin
c'est top je veux dire que ce ton fou
c'est pas trop le maître sith adam est
un peu bloquée que ça dérange et je n'y
crois pas trop que ce soit grave mais
ouais c'est pas d'être drôle quoi
on dit ceci mais la france y gagne en
médailles et renault mai ce qui peut lui
sur une dispense mon nom mais pas qu'eux
en médaillon renault f1 l'urssaf va
passer par là s'ils gagnent des titres
ça va nous rapporter de l'argent la
france est quand même bain ap ap ap un
ba oui mais si tu prends un million
match enfin tu vas quand même oui tu vas
comprendre la pâte est fait une faute
aussi quand tu as choisi et était il
était peut-être pas au courant de tout
où il vient en france vraiment fait très
très bien frère qu ils savent un beau
sur le jeu suivant bâle et 2 millions et
10 13 300 lits frère
il va pas être bien
tu vas payer maintenant tu es français
ben tu parle pas français c'est pas
grave c'est qu'on parle pour toi frère
le toit juste ton rythme s'il te plaît
c'est beau en fait en termes de
l'influent son nom en termes de
financier direct nous avons acquises
comme les six en france c'est très bien
mais reste trop long je sais qu'en
remplaçant mieux quand même
vas-y
c'est un traquenard
qu'on m'envoie je suis ni avec carrière
j'ai plus grand chose
en fait on est très heureux quand on
voudra dire oui il faut vraiment qu'ils
vous fassent de très bons résultats
d'eads est faux
wave à votre carte zen
c'est magnifique
on rigole un petit peu un avec cette
partie elle peut s'emballer après tu as
raison mais faut pas prendre ce fou et
baffe noisy-le-grand tu fais plus rien
adata montus devra fermer à 38 fran
ulmer
donc
peut-être 44
je sais pas je dis aux quatre
navigue kw à
4 h 5 et bien j'en sais
rien de toi indirectes ne sont pas un
peu d'âme normalement mais je me suis
tapé je sais je me suis tapé un rapport
commence à se restaurer mais c'est pas
de l'ispor l'un c'est du sport attention
votre souris ap ap ap un ancien lensois
qui cafouille way
caritatif d'ailleurs
[Rires]
as révoquer une double marc loterie en
fait
sur les dons et au regard de l'autre
côté aussi 100 francs un peu
c'est ce que giza affable du coup en
fait on rigolait tout à l'heure à midi
sur quoi briser du coup parce que du
coup on en fait c'est en scène camille
enfin lui la niche sur twitter qu'il
avait gagné de l'argent sur une opé
caritatives et du coup comme ils ont
fait une seule grosse par déduction
c'est en fait qu'ils ont eu les
incendies en australie et sur foutu les
photos des koalas qui était en train de
mourir dans la forêt bon moi j'étais
triste et où je m'étais c'est pas mal de
faire un truc pour les koalas en fait
c'est magnifique parce que pendant que
les gens c'est bien voilà quoi
c'est vraiment un autre monde les états
unis c'est fou que les cds quoi la route
il n'y a qu'un koala qui est brouillé
j'avais filmé moi un petit j'aime
apporter des forêts fait des trucs pour
quoi la cua et les kangourous et tous
quoi
c'est tellement un autre monde en fait
assez fou
je ne savais quoi faire
un biais dessus
et s'accroît plus aussi on va les
prendre puisque
l'association à gauche mais
heureusement un petit peu aujourd'hui
allez alireza faut sortir un beau coup
je sais trés sympa je pensais que voilà
bah oui sept heures
et j'ai eu un truc incroyable les
comment ils s'appellent les wombats tu
as les bons bats et des gros génie c'est
ce qui est des gens connaissent les
bombes at dans le chat c'est des animaux
qui n'existe qu'en australie
ces genres de gros stocks je sais pas
trop ce qu'ils font ils sont assez gros
ils sont rapides alors il faut un truc
de génie dont ils font plein de deux
tunnels où il a alors creusé creusé
creusé creusé creusé creusé creuse dont
ils sont la phr crosse de partout et
quand il ya des incendies il laisse non
et quand il n'y a pas d' incendies bon
ils te disent dégage je suis chez moi ah
ouais cédé 2,18 tu peux venir il ya le
feu cache toi dans ma maison ressortira
plus tard sortira plus tard du coup on
peut dire que les bombes at un peu
désordre pompiers des animaux quoi et
chinois quand même un billet aux abois
la sortie aussi mais j'étais très
heureux des bombes a du coup c'est
génial ils te font les trous ils sont
pas contents seulement ils sont pas
contents en temps normal et quand les
incendies mon fou on vas tu peux pas et
venez vous asseoir les mecs
ouais non j'étais heureux sais pas
j'étais ouais
ouais ça les bombes at d'habitude ils
bloquent leur terrier avec leur cul
ouais non vraiment ils ont inclus
renforcés ils mettent leur cul devant le
trou 8 et riez pas que tu puisses
contrer l'ordre cuirasse
normalement ils font ça et quand il ya
un incendie il sonné il est rentré
c'est hyper gentil en plus c'est bon
qu'on se fout de leur gueule c'est
vraiment gentil de la savoie ils
bloquent un côté mais l'autre côté conte
et bloque bien ils font qu'un trou il
rentre et sort du
restaurant un tunnel quoi ben brik redit
crosse de dons
et donc ils ont sauvé les quoi là ils
combattent
juste hikaru quoi alors
[Musique]
pire c'est que j'ai failli filer du fric
via ce stream a pour pour les koalas
pour de vrai
j'aurais bien aimé être informé du truc
en amont on peut en partant
il fonde et kkr est aussi ouais mais
voilà enfin
du coup on fable on attend un cac valeo
4 cavaliers h5 ouais
n'hésitez pas hikaru ça c'était le
c'était c'était les bras qui avait fait
cet event briquettes
par un moment il a été il a dit enfin
après je suis pas sur ce stream à je ne
sais pas mais je sais pas si sûr cette
opé spécialement il y avait un truc ou
pas mais c'est par déduction que j'ai
dit ça mais mais bon nous ça aurait pu
être sur une autre pekarik date yves
jean saret non peu importe ce n'est pas
fort c'était pour un petit peu meublé
parler d'échec tout en parlant de demont
bat devons battre
l'animal donc
c'est bien ces thèmes culturels micha
oui oui
amy chaque ivoire bah oui bah oui
je crois qu'elle comprend vraiment
pauvre con à assilah toute la journée
elle passe tout voir de temps en temps
mais
sans avoir quoi
tu montres
j'ai parlé au stream
on
il peut un peu joué avec les cadres dame
des victoires on va voir un
mois c'est pas rien oui miche ouhlala
bah allez viens viens viens voir oui
oh oui toi aussi tu connais les roomba
tu
vas avoir femmes
c'est la petite pause mignonneries du
live en attendant que le 4 kg théréau
micha
d'accord
mais magnifique tu es magnifique michel
chevalet nouvelles des autres à la
poubelle voilà dû venir voir en auto
immune peut-être quelque chose de très
intéressant ici je remet pas du tout en
photo
aucunement
ouais
alors que le 4 qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
fou
je pense que
si tu fais d'amd 8 c'est quoi c'est
vraiment le meilleur coup d'oeil
peut être dû dessine cow
boy
tempête un peu vite fait à 4 à 6 à bab
qui essaient 30
certains grands 3 1
les genres sur qui des six a logiquement
eu
pour le jx pension de merde sens
critique et franck et prendre dame
profonde et quatre trous d'air ouais
après ta d'un boeuf 2
à mailhac et prend des cas depuis qu'on
a mis à en débattre avant dé 4,8 matin
dont je regarde moi qui décide de merde
non dame 17
ans mais bon
on sait absolument rien n'en sais rien
donc je sais pas quoi madame des 8
à 4 assists vacarme logique à bab hockey
et la fourche est attaqué c'est trop
c'est qu'on a maintenant il part sur du
dame bien son nombre
d'années peut-être pas mal et sur tourbe
et 8 ça je me demande quel problème si
c'est d'un prentice d'un premier 5
et ça peut être quelque chose donc c'est
pour ça que
donc oui sur dame projet phoques et ça
c'est vraiment je suis un joueur avec
les noirs date encore d'effacer vos
trucs tusk avait gagné là c'est chiant
des
biens peuvent être enfin trouvé des
cavaliers à 3 des coupures étaient un
peu par harmonie avec des pièces
désordonnée coup et si la dame qui est
ultra dur
et pourquoi c'est une force d'âme b3 du
tout toutes ces dames petrov prend des
quatre
d'accord bon arrêtons il t'aime bien
reprendre et 4 tu défends mes donc ça
change plus fort d un étude mais non je
pensais aussi mais qu'ils en métro
située à défend c'est quoi la dit
parce qu'en fait ça il peut rater à ta
tour un
tas de gravats et si la dame héros et
adam prend un tour pour des ivresses
walk et sai baba
sylla en fait ça peut être
un peu pénible ça peut être un peu
pénible
est michaille un espoir
qui nous a porté chance
alors que l'eire de rien parce que la
position elle paraît vraiment anodine
anodine ouais
en fait faut pas grand chose pour soi et
n'est pas chaud qu apparemment
complètement en force et ça peut être
des bonnes nouvelles il ya peut-être un
streamer qui se placent
ces pressions d'un point dé 5 c 4 dames
4e f 1 dames g4 fallait faire de mme
burns
après ce que c'est si grave
moi je suis tout de suite sur est
content que nakaa gagne
[Musique]
puis déjà ça ramène tout le monde sait
en fait si ali riza gagné n'a qu'à y
gagner franchement
t'as que des mecs à +1 tf1 n'y a rien
fait hier
bon ok on a peut-être gagné aujourd'hui
aussi attention il faut les opus de
waimes et boit sa journée il peut perdre
aussi un oui
je suis tout a
fait d être ce qu
ils voulaient pas petit rock qui avait
acheté quatre fois chacun pour aider h5
non mais je comprendrais
caruana ce genre de position qu'on se
rapporte ça peut être dangereux parce
que c'est moi n'importe quoi il peut
être fort
vas-y fab femme qui fait un break
ok donc n'est pas en danger car ouanna
se passe pas si bien radjabov contre
ding
pour laurence a ajout mrdja pas en sueur
du tout
en vrai de vrai les gars si firoud déjà
gagné aujourd'hui on peut on y croit
complètement en fait
on y croit complet non
ça peut
ça peut complètement relancé
le joueur français
c'est dur de gagner ouais mais en fait
si la dame des 8 à 4 à 6 bouffer dame b
1 en vrai c'est dur mais bon il peut
enfin faut à un moment donné si on veut
gagner il faut avoir une séquence de
cours un jour quand même ça peut devenir
un peu dangereux
étonnamment tu peux mettre la clim celle
qui est là ça peut peut-être nous skis
ouais ouais ce qui commence il commence
à faire chaud merci mon fab
bien joué sûr qu'à un moment donné si tu
veux gagner une partie me faire faire
une bonne séquence en ouverture
duda qui commence à réfléchir il ya
peut-être un petit quelque chose
j'espère qu'il a trouvé dabin est très
ferme à spa pas facile à voir mais
on est quand même sur des joueurs de top
niveau donc on espère qu'à un moment
donné il ya une séquence quoi
s'il n'y a jamais eu une seule séquence
n'est in ça va être dur de gagner quand
même n'est ce pas fable exactement
on est en droit d'attendre
des couffins comme ça
jusqu'à la maman viens de l'expliquer en
fait tu
viens de l'expliquer mais sera un coup
fort parce que ça tapera b5 et
voilà bien des projets il y aura un
problème de huitième rang j'ai en face
ça vient appuyer sur sur des points
faibles adverses
voire la cam est-ce que duda et ça sert
à table en plus d'amener un
bob dylan des huit bons c'est le moment
de vérité toualy raisin à la séquence à
quatre à six dames bien auquel cas il va
falloir que duda soit un petit peu
précis soit il n'a pas du tout et
moins qu'on ait raté quelque chose ça ça
pourrait être zéro pression monte mais
il doit jouer quand même un bon coup un
moment donné
allez il faut avoir une séquence
jouer une séquence de coûts
tempo il va le faire il est déjà pas si
bien que ça autant heureusement que la
position n'est pas trop complexe qui
restent de plus de 42 minutes
du coup
ce qui paraît assez mais vu sa cadence
jusqu'à maintenant ça peut
ça pourrait ne pas être assez
comme le milan
a été géré ça là
d'où d'ailleurs qui qui a joué aussi non
ehpad ou d'un jeune gardien de but did a
dit
le brésilien brésil un gardien butin
était bon
et dudek de liverpool
york s'était dit ah ouais
bon va dénouer en chat si je me trompe
mais
dida qui avait d'ailleurs dit doigts
ouais
ça fatigue côté commentateurs ben c'est
pas une partie évidente aujourd'hui
parce que
cela soit masse de choses il faut que là
il trouve le a4 ou venant bien
après sera doux doit de trouver mais en
gros ça peut très vite être complètement
égal si un petit coup imprécis des
blancs quoi les noirs juste tu donnes
juste la même position et cash sicilia
plus la même thème qui marche pas ce qui
a pu les maths du couloir où tu laisses
solidifier bessin et coucou à basta donc
c'est très concret
et
bon même s'il trouve le truc avec dame
bien
non mais c'est loin d'être fini ainsi
jusque tu auras une petite pression par
bddp et voilà ça désagréable ben ah bon
il faut quand même qu'ils trouvent un
moment donné enfin
oui ça se trouve pas ça va être dur
facile voilà c'est ça le truc
qui est g5 bail se fait bouffer en fait
il défend trop bien avec dame d'haïti
fouilles 6 n'empêche ça aurait été un
joli coup ci avait pas d'un projet cinq
ici ce serait bien joué
donc tu vois si avec eux j'ai ici sda
match 3 3 qui je vais toujours un
preneur zinc dame f3 et là on pourrait
on commençait vraiment à taper quoi
donc c'est quand même un coup c'est un
joli coup qu'a réalisé cinq
aînés choc encore magnifique on est à
deux coups de suite
position
coordonnée blanc et peut-être que c'est
bien on va prendre un peu d espace avec
des seins qui est un village où il a
joué ça a joué côté à côté français il a
joué à quatre que non seulement ça c'est
logique à 6 on va voir si la bonjour à
tous j'ai une question j'ai vite
sérieusement les échecs mais nous
demande si la chance n'est pas également
un facteur dans ce genre de tournoi le
sens si on connaît des petites lignes
complètes d'ouverture précise alors il
peut prendre l'aventage la prison que
l'autre non et oui et c'est ça les
échecs et ccc aussi de la chance
n'admettons que là ils jouent d'amd 6
par exemple pour réagir à 4 non mais je
veux dire tu as de la réussite c'est pas
de la chance et de la réussite comme un
village effet dame décide pour montrer
un coup un peu légère ya tueur de la
réussite dans un tournoi que ton
adversaire tomber dans un bon jour un
mauvais jour la bonne ouverture mais
comme dans n'importe quel sport il faut
de la réussite après la dans ton exemple
parce que c'est pas que de la chance
aussi que toi tu as travaillé et n'être
pas trop quoi donc que tu
[Musique]
mets évidemment de la forme du gal
aussi tu peux ne pas avoir de chance et
que c'est qu'il allait travailler un
truc pour je compte chez pas acquis que
le che paquet en question ne va pas
jouer donc que ça gênait voilée est en
fait un jour tu as en toi des choses
comme ça c'est la vie et où admettons
par exemple sur cinq mois tu joues
contre allan et pète ua qui fait une
mauvaise partie contre naqab on verra si
ça se concrétise nuit magique n'est pas
sur les manger des sushis hier soir non
mais ça fait partie
des soucis nés des dégâts ça soit
je rigole mais en vrai ça m'arrive des
fois de parler avec maxime qu après le
tournoi et il y arrive qu'ils aient des
parties de merde ce que je vais pas
citer au des mauvaises parties ou justin
il était pas bien sûr toute la saison
sur les centaines de parties qui joue
jamais réellement oui oui tous pas mal
dormi j'ai juste hâte a fait nul là
c'était compte faire nul l'om est enfin
ça peut ça arrive en fait le choix mes
joueurs c'est de la réussite aussi tout
le jour où le mec enfin
à chaque fois les joueurs rigolent quand
j'étais pas pourquoi tout se foutent de
ma gueule je dis ça mais en plus c'est
tellement réel imaginez que je sais pas
combien de jours vous êtes malades par
an je sais pas on est peut-être malades
j'en sais rien moi cinq jours par an en
moyenne un petit rhume un petit truc 5
10 jours la taille inec x 21 jours de
tournoi donc potentiellement tata
quasiment 200 jours de vie
donc sur 200 jours de vie qui est
quelqu'un qui sont un peu malade en plus
avec le stress ou quoi c'est normal par
des brûlures d'estomac tu peux avoir la
chiasse tu peux avoir ma la tête le
rhume fin
une mononucléose j'en sais rien moi
plein de choses et du coup tu tombe
dessus le jour où il est malade non mes
vaches à lait à chaque fois on prend
pour un con quand je dis ça me rend fou
parce que c'est tellement réel alors on
a joué des parties des failles de mal de
tête tout ça c'est un vrai
bon matin sur que tu peux faire nul là
tu sautes de sucre
et
tu peux avoir un mal de dents imagine tu
as une rage de dents là ni dans mes
schémas ya plein de trucs en fait est ok
tu tombes le lendemain la partie moins
bien mieux fins et puis même l'ordre des
appariements bah oui à une époque hyper
une fois qu'ils tilt c'est plus dur mais
en contrôlerait city tequila chasse en
même temps
une petite au titre mais voilà donc il
ya aussi ça non
donc assis ou même tu vas tu joues ding
qui est encore en jet lag à la honda
il ya plein de facteurs qui rentrent en
ligne de compte un
jour
moi ça m'est déjà arrivé moi je pense
sommet qui exclut non non moi ça m'est
arrivé l arbitre a changé d'échiquier
d'éclater pour
crack il a vomi une deuxième fois et
j'ai proposé ni j'en avais
très content que
je déclare comme une troisième fois que
non mais après style c'était une partie
importante pour moi je veux absolument
gagner je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça
mais juste ça m'a saoulé qui vomit
charge ça m'a rendu fou
mais ça m'est déjà arrivé mais qd vomi
dessus l arbitre a pas du tout donné
point quoi vtt nul quoi c'est pas
possible
je connais pas les règles a tué mauvais
jeu pour sanctionner avec mais il ya un
problème de respect de l'adversaire
tout comportement et tout ça quoi
passer une méga va se traîner aux
toilettes et vomit et bon voila tu peux
pas dire en famille sur la tragique et
la sef
ont peu importe
il ya un mec qui va aussi fait un
hématome au pied il ya rien du futur un
[ __ ] de coups de pied
il m'a défoncé j'avais un [ __ ]
d'hématomes après j'avais 10 ans ou 11
ans n'y a pas eu forfait du tout un mec
a continué de la partie est perdue
quatre coups après il a tué au moins je
vois enfin basset al assad où est le mec
est tombé il m'a défoncé le pied j'avais
11 ans je suis allé faire un scanner
après parce que je savais pas s'ils
mettaient pas casser un truc mais j'ai
jamais eue gagné partie gagnée
je sais pas ce qui se passait avec une
barre de fer et tu te défonces le gant
fin faudrait essayer on pourra gagner
les candidats fab aussi
candidat 4
passes
on peut importe mais là c'est enfin ali
reza enfin on rigole on rigole en fait
c'est soit il trouve soit il trouve pas
et je suis un qui lui reste plus de 34
minutes je sais pas à quoi il réfléchit
depuis une heure et demie franchement
vu les affiches des vrais coups c'est
vrai que c'est la première heure de
réflexion est un peu perdu qu on va dire
ce qui si ce qui c'est qui a démarré à
faire
mais bon tout ça c'est au niveau amateur
bien évidemment au niveau professionnel
je sais pas si ce qui honnêtement je
connais pas la russie a des arbitres sur
intéressés pour la peine c'est toujours
j'aime bien les points arbitrage les
points règle
non mais tu vois globalement
est-ce que c'est indécent est-ce que
coco enfin qu'est ce qui est prévu par
le règlement je pense
que je suis dit je suis arbitre d'échec
jean sergent sais rien mais les chances
oui ils ont jamais songé au k way mais
enfin c'est pour ce à quoi s'est
ils ont pensé qu' il faut voir 10 nuls à
l'infini mais pas ça
et on dit il car on web on n'en sait pas
gagnant c'est la variante
nom mé li pa modou
diagne ans
il centre dans la catégorie des
rangements de l'adversaire et du coup il
se passe quoi si tu te dérange
l'adversaire
ben c'est pas bien mais c'est quoi ces
avertissements ou c'est non mais là tu
déranges adversaire tu déranges
l'échiquier tu déranges les voisins tu
déranges le tournoi en fait fallu
dérange vraiment tout
en plus contagieuse ça peut
potentiellement être dangereux non ça
doit être forte en fait
les conduite inadéquate s'était même via
du temps je pense même pas que forfait
de la partie ouest et à dernière ronde
oui ça aurait pu juste être forfait
[Musique]
en tout cas écart où ça va à jouer et
alireza bah écoute on attend et gestion
du temps quand même étonnant de ski
robinson raciale mais en fait il fait ça
tous les ans et pour ça que je te dise
et il fait ça depuis le début du tournoi
pour moi il ya quelque chose qui tourne
pas rond et juste c'est pas logique en
fait car on n'y
avait pas eu de coup je crois
et c'est ça pas bougé depuis le talent
du hockey on vit et ding
j'imagine
non mais ça la gestion du temps au temps
a dit qu'à route c'est ça qui me fait
dire qu'il n'est pas dans son assiette
aux
chirurgiens pardon ça qui me fait à pied
par l'ancien n 7 et je me répète pour la
25e fois du tournoi mais c'est c'est pas
cesser trop saccadé
tu vas faire à quatre matchs enfin fait
que d'écologie qu'à chaque fois tu
réfléchis 15 minutes y a personne qui
joue comme ça en fait
et pour moi c'est un manque de confiance
trop de pression je sais pas mais à
quelque chose qui va pas c'est pas
normal de faire ça on est d'accord
toi qui es grand maître oui non c'est
pas chez des coûts un peu plus vite je
te fais pas tu aimes boal et une minutes
tu voues non mais tempo non mais
reprendre 6 minutes après quoi tient de
fer tempo sur le couple à vue peuvent
mais en fait tu fais à 4 a réfléchi simi
tu penses à quel coût à part à 6 et le
coût principal ont battu pour ça rien
d'autre que je suis en fait et puis
comment tu peux réfléchir qu'un vrai nom
il ya un problème pour ali reza je ne
sais pas comment l'expliquer je sais pas
toi fab quel est ton interprétation
est ce que sur ab il va réfléchir six
minutes
défense est dû au stress est due à trop
de préparation pas à ces pratiques
je sais que tu sais pas mais
surtout qui pas spécialement bien autant
il reste trente minutes pour 15 coups
alors c'est pas alarmant mais
tu vois là à bab normale en moi je vous
quand meme temp un
même à haut niveau ne s'est pas neuf
fois sur dix le mec va jouer tempo oui
il est vraiment capable de reprendre dix
minutes
6 à 4 il réfléchit sur un 6 ab livrera
fait sur ab1 place comme s'il ya peu de
coups on veut des noms savants à 80
c'est très étonnant et c'est très
inquiétant en fait
c'est un peu comme grille ou que comme
nivelage les appelle les time rebelle
john key c'est une maladie qui est dur à
soigner derrière
cela il ya ça fait juste pas de sens en
fait
si tu sais que sur abeba tu savais que
sur à katia les assisses tu sais que sur
abbey ab ça fait déjà plus d'une minute
ça fait réellement 0 sens
je met même à niveau amateur tu vois
rarement de ce genre de gestion du temps
c'est extrêmement étonnant
on ne mangera amazoo ce qu'ils en
pensent mais
est ce qu'ils faisaient ça où je me
d'ora pourquoi je pense pas non non
c'est très étonnant
et c3 n'a pas trouvé de thème des 7
écoles
oui c'est pas le coup on espérait est
juste dame 17 va défendre b5
et
caen
est basiquement assez violent quoi
ouais c'est étonnant
oui c'est vrai je sais pas si c'est pas
mis trop de pression il a essayé de se
lever en disant que je vais pas le gars
machin et tout mais peut-être dans sa
tête abete a beau dire ce que tu en
conférence ça change parce que tu penses
au fond de toi
une fois depuis je joue le titre tu ne
joues pas du tout tu le sais des fois tu
dis je joue pas mais tu sais que tu es
là pour ça
carrier s'est alors c'est pas bizarre
hein c'est le premier coup auquel on
pensait qu'ils étaient pas le coup de
l'ordi pour le club et son attaque et v5
mais il serait juste que damien est un
coup vraiment difficile la logique enfin
logique mais ça tenait que sur la times
ces genres de cook ali reza pouvait
avoir justement
aux basques et ce sera oui c'est un côté
logique on contre la casse devant
d'autres pions pour peut-être faire des
cinq un jour était de faire bloquer
dessus on attaque b 5e tour but pour le
défendre ne va pas parce qu'on fait
juste quatre options
mais le défenseur bon c'est vrai même
d'un coup comme dame des sept îles plus
logique de tous bas ça défend b5
aurait de faire peut-être tour 8es
changer la tour sur eux
et puis on a plus la pression sur le fou
orbitz elle reste qu'on peut revenir en
jeu 4 rebonds oui ma passion avec ce
bilan fait oui
monsieur claude robichaud exactions
guéri de son nom
mais m bon ça peut même mal se passer en
fait cela il ya plus davantage du tout
madame de cette approche est passé jeudi
paris cyril thorel mal et urbain en tête
vitres
torride
amchud lutins que je sais pas qui avait
lieu j'ai peut-être un truc à temps j'ai
une idée
en fait je voulais ça et qui sait si ce
média dames 8 je voulais dame c7 et c6
désarmant suffisamment spatiale c'est
joli ouais mais bon juste dames 8 et
d'amr mat
pour se le dise et j'en ai vraiment bien
je te passe embarquement
la fée dame 17 et du vous tombez un tour
b 8 h vaste au juteux revenus totaux
d'autres s'attachent aussi ses
mérites a raison ça va devenir même plus
facile à jouer au noir pizza a évolué
j'ai un peu juste pression du top 12 oui
oui je trouve ça désagréable geste
option central passé isolé de merde
bloqué et le pion sur elle qu'il faut
avancer très passe agréable c'est un peu
désagréable
et 6 1 de répéter les coups de
simplifier dans
partie très décevant quand même on va
pas on va pas se cacher
badou deuil l'occasion tous les tempos
après 40 minutes mais pas d'intenses
réflexions
ancien de près par essayer de faire
tomber 5 juste ça marchait sur ses tops
qu'il aime bien ça va marcher de la
faire à part ça il n'a pas trop
réfléchir
mais oui la prépa je sais pas assez
étonnant bond il avait juste pas prévu
le truc qu alors ses limites larmes
principal non et surtout en fait ce qui
est bizarre c'est qu'il n'est pas du
tout réfléchi à aqaba fin du coup si
t'as pas du tout prévu la petrov aurait
pu réfléchir au monde cinq
turcs et fils d'atteindre le tour de
turquie et c'est ron kirk je sais pas
quel truc
étonnant parce qu'il est rentré vraiment
en force dans ce truc
en fait qui n'est pas si mal mais
est très amer
en tout cas pour moi clairement il ya
quelque chose qui va pas pour ali reza
dans ce tournoi s'est passé pas son
niveau de jeu maximum ça c'est sûr
on l'a vu mieux jouer et fab est ce que
comme on le disait avant il était en
surrégime dans les autres tournois est
ce que l'ail s'est trop mis la pression
il ya beaucoup d'explications
possibles
ce qu'il est malade
non mais ce genre de souche et c'est pas
après s'il avait la chasse c'est vrai
j'ai un peu plus vite je pense qu'on
doit pas non non ça ça doit aller
ce qu'il est dépassé par la pression est
ce qu'il est dépassé par le niveau de
jeu des adversaires et ce que
est ce qu'il est mal entouré est ce que
est ce que c'est juste la faute à pas de
chance
il ya beaucoup de possibilités
d'interrogations auxquelles on ne peut
pas vous répondre
aux les mêmes questions vous on a pas on
n'a pas la réponse on connaît pas on
n'est pas dans les petits papiers ou are
not in the little papers comme comme
disent les américains
jeunes in
on peut pas on peut pas vraiment savoir
et décide de tout simplifier il veut
tout simplifier
con ça marche vrai que ces prises des 5
prises des 5 prises des 5 tour à tour
c'est ça tombe bien dame bien il faut
des quatre vingt 80 ans
non mais alors là je dis lui toi que
c'était fou des cas alors c'est fou des
quatre ici oui ouais avec tour à tour
bien fou dès 4h mans c'est comme ça ça
avancera mathieu
fritz de mes fins
padam prendre et royaux restera huit
matches
aller ce jeu la finale de pions
les punto
et qui était si simple
finalement vlada était prémonitoire dans
un sens mais sur un truc qui l'a dit un
an il ya huit ou neuf mois
décor façon qu'on me dit tout et son
contraire l'autre côté pour pouvoir
marcher mais il disait qu'il pensait que
cramique c'était un très mauvais choix
aura dur à dire
sur le papier sur papier c'est un très
bon choix
su
après peut-être enfin j'en sais rien je
pense qu au telegraph nick c'est bien
pour ta compréhension des chèques machin
après peut-être que c'est pas le coach
idéal pour gagner une compétition à
court terme mais pour tous son apport
qui l'aura long terme sur ça peut pas
être mal c'est quand même un des géants
qu'on ait eue récemment comme
tu possèdes kasparov à petit rien
apporté sur le coup le cycle là mais bon
tu es content d'avoir sa vision ça pour
être avec eux ma demande
ces trois-là nantes est content de faire
des échecs avec une touche un peu les
pièces
de créateurs et de lattes s'était elle
était toute autre
c'est ce qu'un tel comme allende a
vraiment envie que tu réussisses donc
ramené comme calme
lui l'a vraiment vu que tu as réussi
à parcourir pour vie ce qui n'est pas
juste là pour prendre son chèque oui
mais bon un moment il veut continuer à
toucher des chèques pendant longtemps
faut pas qu'il soit se trouve aux
habitations russie en tête sera pas
impliqué à 100% si l'apa un affect de
fou mais là pas de dire de la merde
explique faire gratter je fais l'avocat
du diable j'aime beaucoup cramé qu'en
fait mais c'est possible enfin je dirais
comme un couche de foot des fois tu peux
tu partir d'une équipe tourne en train
d'une autre
bah tu préférais que ton club de coeur
gagner mais bon tu es là tu es là et
puis tu vas pas perdre le match par
plaisir on prétendra plus personne de ta
vie puisqu'ils y ont été grillés
ou pas
non mais la toile ce un tennis comparer
contre par l'arrière segal qui s'était
qualifiée en entrée en lice bon quand on
mène 2 0 et que baisser les bras ils
ressentiront se maintenir comme ça coûte
pour autant mais quatre dans la gueule
il fait entrer deux attaquants il change
de schémas de jeu il fait son match quoi
alors qu en fait d'un point de vue
extérieur
après de magie mais bon bah j'espère
s'interdit enfin il est bien sûr et bon
pendant le match il joue son match et
passer comme ça
complexe fab
england radjabov ça a l'air d'aller tout
à tout tout tranquillement vers la nulle
caruana rapporte ça a l'air d'être la
partie chaude du jour on y reviendra
mais l'évènement ça pourrait être la
victoire
hikaru cette affaire encore faire loin
même de feu
alors dit donne quand même complètement
gagnant même
1,5750 profondeur
25 généralement ça pue
non mais les mieux ce serait beau poème
qui quarante ans cette dame detroit les
fragiles que s'il ya des trucs qui se
passent tu peux lui faire des dessins
grec
va dire des choses qui se passent dans
la position
sicav ou gagnent les candidats cet homme
est incroyable déjà se qualifier j'y
crois pas du tout mais être à +16 la
puce après cinq rondes c'est
exceptionnel en ayant perdu leur
première absolument exceptionnelle j'ai
pas les mots en fait c'est je trouve ça
beau
je trouve ça hallucinant en fait
c'est
c'est cosmique en fait en plus si je
vais pas trop bien quand il a changé de
main stream heures mais non là tu
reviens dans les parties lentes je
dirais et quand il a joué les grands
prix se sortir au premier tour il
faisait plus gros défi a offert par
topal of norway
et donc tu te dis ouais voilà enfin est
d'ailleurs lui même avait pas insisté je
vais plus là il revient mais pas prêt
fin je veux bien sûr qu'à l'époque il a
passé à travailler j'imagine je suis la
fessée blitz estrie ben may il joue
mieux qu'avant
parce qu'il literally jason qu'hier on
sait par contre c'est vraiment le mind
7-6 a acquis son rôle et qui il joue
juste pour le plaisir et qu' il veut
planter ses trucs et ses fans de perdre
et que c'est vraiment ce qu'ils pensent
peut-être qu'il est vraiment libérés et
que c'est plus facile
elle sera inscrit merci libéré c'est
pourtant pas si facile
et tu vois c'est un peu l'un verse
d'alireza quelque part en si si on
regarde en fait ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'allié reza ce qu'ils ont un
style qui pourrait quand même être
semblable mais qui caroube on a tout à
fait pareil mais il pourrait y avoir des
similitudes et alirio celle inverse
absolument sûr préparé
et il déjoue complètement l'enjeu et
hikaru tu dis ces ouvertures ces quand
même trop il vous fait la même chose et
tout mais dans le jeu il joue bien il
joue très très bien et ça fait la
différence c'est ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant fait côté observateurs tu
vois de se dire tiens c est ça me fait
penser un peu s'ils assurent la méta
qu'apporter manuscrits oui bon au lieu
de me préparer quatre heures le matin je
préfère dormir boire des jus d'orange
arrivera la partie jetez vous cette
heure et puis on verra si tu sais josé
chaque face
je trouve que c'est pas si clownesque
qui anodin que ça en fait non non non
little john meilleurs seconds en du
monde ben ouais mais
en gros calculs sur un calcul mais c'est
plus fraîcheur mentale et physique ouais
mais on le voit la sq alireza sa prépa
dans cette partie là c'est zéro et
finalement si la fraîcheur pour trouver
dame b1 et qu'il est frais comme un
gardon et kloet a trahi 4 heures ce
matin qu'une plante d'âme des uns et qui
te reste une heure 30 contre 20 ou 40
minutes chacun va peut-être tu va le
battre en fait
et
par le mieux c'est d'avoir les deux
c'est vrai les grosses prêt passe un peu
ce que fait magnus et la fraîcheur oui
j'ai souvent du mauvais travail quand
même bien et de réviser un petit peu et
bien mais
ils vont quand tu es plus fort sa f1
globalement plus fort ça d'aussi à avoir
un éventail de position plus intéressant
à jouer et c'est mes mails car oui
montre face à ce qu'on en discute et à
leurs amis dit on se disait que carlson
finalement lui quand il arrivait à
gagner les candidats et qu'il arrivait à
son premier championnat du monde il
était très mauvais dans les ouvertures
un très mauvais il était mauvais dans
les ouvert c'était son point faible par
rapport aux autres mais il surclasse est
vraiment dans le jeu et puis cette ville
à gommer ce à dire non et même mieux
préparés à l'époque
ça faisait pas rêver les deux versions
et comme rafa qui avait pas un bon
service quand il arrivait et qui est
attirée à changer son jeu mais et
alireza well as pour le moment il est
très très bon dans les ouvertures mais
ouais un peu moins dans les finales
notamment
c'est vraiment un truc des champions ce
soir se remettre en cause même quand ils
viennent quand même quand même
d'améliorer
encore plus
il daramy bon résultat pour gagner sa
vie ça peut être épuisant mentalement
après ils gagnent vraiment gagner très
très très très très très très très bien
sa vie donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment genre se trempe là je pense que
toi qui s'apprennent financière
beaucoup trop riches il veut tendre avec
des barbus et c'est le problème de
joueurs pas de moi on fait ça
ou même à rognan au début c'est vrai que
quand j'avais pu parler avec une fois il
disait que c'était cool qu'on n'avait pu
partir vivre en allemagne parce que il
avait l'esprit libéré le plus de
tournois gagner sa vie machin et que
c'était pas pareil que quand il vivait
en harmonie au tout début et on cuit
mais là pour quelqu'un qui est dans le
fan a que moi tu es numéro deux mondial
quand même
ça va enfin je pense pas qu'ils se
demandaient bien ce que je mange à la
fin du mois
et c'est tant mieux oui mais voilà quand
même vrai
il a dit aussi qu un échec était plus
heureux dans sa vie ça j'y crois plus
par contre ça je pense que ça peut
réellement influer positivement
assilah gros pari ou qu'il ya des
preuves à côté ça c'est autre chose mais
je crois pas particulièrement mais la
wii dont il a l'air content de ce qu'il
fait il fait son truc
bon va devoir tout échange et puis une
petite news rapidos voilà non annoncée
va tout droit
après 12h accueil écoute et théoriques
ou des premiers aligner fio a pas fait
d'erreurs donc pas vraiment être déçus
de nulle part il a quand même raté le à
bab at dawn berne ouais et non mais ce
cadre des sorts c'est quand tu allais
blanc tu dois soumettre un plan de fuite
chez l'adversaire et si je joue bien il
fera nuit là il y là il n'est pas à
mettre en danger du tout donc le titre
déception apprennent déshonorant fermé
demain la victoire sera réellement
obligatoire un
corner
rennais mais est ce que est ce que d'un
autre côté c'est pas là pas la partie où
il sera le plus écoute on verra mais
s'ils gagnent pas demain - après six
rondes
il parait il paraît quand même un peu un
peu décramponner ci gagne demain ça
remet tout les pendules à l'heure et
puis y aura 7 demain
son énergie
car les noirs il sera contente pas
perdre après si ça joue que cette faille
qui fera s'il peut presser de gagner
avec les dents aussi mais tu demanderas
avant la partie te dirai oui nul c'est
bien
prendre quatre
c'est ça la variante qui devrait arriver
enfin cette demain 7 demain avec seb on
est jamais trop sur un os pierre
chevassu sera à l'arrêt en bec
l'empereur des cases noires et vendredi
1 le match
pardon à wendy le match fade krikor beau
match de gala mon fab
ouais il faut cliquer
enfin je travaille un peu avant je
prépare puis on verra pour affaires
la furia brésilienne
il est dangereux
wes illimitée après faut c'est ne pas
s'y prendre au dernier moment parce que
les places à l'hôtel seront pas
forcément
accessible jusqu'au bout mais tu vois je
vais pas vous dire oui deadline
absolument là mais si vous avez envie de
venir à vous le savez
ça sans rien attendre voilà donc comme
je vous disais il ya deux stages fait
qu'on fait qu'elle du 13 au 20 à
lisbonne
bill son expérience
voilà donc on va y aller on voit bien
vous accueillir on fera les échecs le
matin
après midi un peu plus libre visite un
quartier libre envie de dire on prend un
tournant aussi entre les stagiaires et
donc on aura six jours de travail bien
comme il faut beau rob harris et à
progresser et passer des bons moments et
dévoilera donc lisbonne en plus super
ville on sera au bord de la mer c'est
cool
et puis après on fait un deuxième avec
maso
vers barcelone pas barcelone mais une
demi heure ça pourrait pas faire pour
les noirs est donc le deuxième il est
juste après 24 28 août
voilà donc si jamais tu as le lien
peut-être fait le formulaire pour
je vais le tenter je vais tenter parce
que là ya une personne de que vous avez
écrit hier un pour lisbonne donc
écrivait toute façon ça engage à rien
décriront pour donner toutes les infos
ça vous plaît bah tant mieux sinon ça
pourrait être une autre année ou deux
choses ce n'est pas un souci mais ça
fait une petite prouesse d'infos si un
niveau mini pas vraiment alors pas si
vous êtes vraiment trop trop trop super
débutants
on essaiera de fans mise à niveau si
possible mais toute façon il ya un peu
de de tous les niveaux je dirais on est
de en plus sur place donc on peut se
répartir
donc personne ne sera laissé pour compte
donc c'est bien la variante qu'on avait
donné un qui est en train de se jouer
c'est maintenant sur l'échiquier je vais
mettre la cam en grand fabre g mis le
lien je ramène deuxième fois au phrasé
express
je pense qu'on fera une autre partie ce
soir ce que celle là il ya vraiment rien
à dire on va faire une petite pause
avant le résumé express histoire de fou
bien bien fait bien soufflé ray la
chance pour ce sens sera n'a qu'à sidi
dhrif peut-être gagner on verra où
caruana selon qu'on la partie
je te rien quoi balance à la elle sera
qu en express
tomber un homme bien un petit coup de
pied droit est nul
allez une petite d'euros non les blancs
ya des pages sélection massive et des
clous agent fait des pièces pour épauler
sur l'amitié manger
mes choix ils n'ont pas leur avant le
40e d'accord
sur les dates pour lisbonne 13 au 20
août
je remets le lien dans le chat un génie
déjà de trois fois mais les gens leur
hat trick est cliquable
ça se voit que ça répète professionnelle
elle serait bon qu'ils répètent pas
c'est la soupe à la grimace un quand
même côté français
j'ai pas très heureux de la regardent
ils jouent avec demain
débute well et les dégoûter
ils sont qui joue malin forcément
non mais la mauvaise réponse pas de
prépa en fait
un poil la rouverture
complexe
très complet
très heureux qu'il a dit hier très vite
c'était pas perdre dans ce tournoi bon
bah quand tu sa stratégie de ne pas
perdre voilà pour total c'est une bonne
partie
il est tranquille as tu ferais
tranquille domaine rural et violent il
va
au quai de la petite pause alors attends
on fait juste un oui on va laisser
voilà où écrire en fait on va voir
suivant qui déteignent équipe
alors timour dingli rennes ça joue ouais
mais ça commence à dire que ding a
peut-être un petit quelque chose dans le
chat est bon à voir non mais comme il
l'a fait aux 84e fait des trucs radjabov
donc tu peux te prendre un contre-feu ou
pas j'ai ressassé très solide mais c'est
pas ça va pas faire nul direct comme ça
sans rien
dépôts non c'est pas ça ouais
pour webhelp a pas trop bien mais c'est
loin d'être perdu
ça peut être sûr de ce qui va se passer
viens de jouer cavalier hausse est en
tout cas le coût principal
et donc il nous reste caruana rapporte
au mont là c'est compliqué c'est juste
compliqué à les bleus ont par ok il
rompt pas peut-être droit à partir à se
cacher de lui-même à la main où ils
seront mieux parce que c'est pas ce
permis
on verra très compliqué position un peu
un peu fofolle moi je propose qu'on vous
laisse sur la caméra di caro avec la
position du karoun on va se faire un une
petite coupure et on revient dans 5 à 10
minutes pour le résumé express de la
partie
d'alireza et pour suivre la fin de cette
journée qui s'annonce palpitante à tout
de suite en 5 10 minutes les gars
profitez-en bien di caro
est donné peau
les amis désolé en fait y'a vlad qui va
venir on a un peu organisé les choses
et du coup et on a bouffé des cookies
aussi
et on va vous faire le résumé
mais juste il fallait voilà qu'on se met
en place
à les cookies cookies chocolat acheté en
boulangerie c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment bon
quelle marque non mais c'est pas des
marques pour athènes
on a arrêté d'acheter
d'acheter des marques
yo yo yo
petit résumé le résume à dos
les coûts franchement
c'est je suis apparemment la partie on
refait juin juste par curiosité cissé ou
la foule s'est passé des trucs un peu
partout une dame en g7 et des clous âge
rajhi kangding caisse un peu pareil ça
par contre ça bouge pas des masses mais
il peut se passer des choses c'est pas
nul
by le résumé qui a acquis par mois en
fin de set up
on est en allemand s'attaque aux manèges
qui est vide normal on est bien là non
mais oui mais en fait ça s'est enlevé
pour alors résumée à au cas où c'est en
fait c'est raymond pacte et augure de
très très bien quand on est très très
bien faux cloudy que le fasse mais il
n'est pas connecté
hamon prend à faire
ce qu'elle vient le clip
bas il est connecté quoi bon ben on va
le faire quand même et puis se
débrouillera
c'est ce que je te propose à l'est
ok allez sa part
d'un club de deux
rives du rio la fine fleur
ouais en fait résumé puis après un
problème strike blad répondre à ma place
sur lequel seul de nous deux
va être très bien que mischa qu'on
en autonomie
bar quoi
ego attend
vous l'adefa brest
je peux rester
bas ou fabre ou la non autonomie un
poisson on a eu tout ce qu'on avait à
dire en fait aujourd'hui oui
bon on peut lancer vlad et puis après il
se lance et on va vous fait des coups
qui
s'est beaucoup qui au chocolat
mois les consciences un deux trois
actions
donc favori lui cinquième partie à des
candidats et alireza fille round jackie
avaient les pièces blanches contre
jean-christophe duda et alireza qui
avait besoin de marquer le point pour se
refaire de sa défaite de la veille
contre yann nepomniachi ali reza qui
envoie e4 e5 de la part de duda une demi
surprise mais j'ai même envie de dire
pas tant que ça à fab voilà un kart
surprise à des noms mais qui va jouer sa
petrov qui est son abattoir principal et
solide contre 4 et ce qui a surpris
alireza malheureusement après des 6 kg 3
qui prend 1,4 des cas concrets dans les
grandes lignes des 5 fu des trois fois
f540 que 12ème bien joué contre la
petrov pour pouvoir ensuite échanger
votre case blanche petit rock fawcett
tourin place à tour soit que l'on
ouverte petit rock et bd doit tacle
cavaliers en a quatre qui seront patrie
en d6 défend dans son fief cinq
cavaliers fin comme ça sur france 3
pourra reprendre de la dame et passe de
l'ailé pions ces 6 kg trois attaques le
f5 du coude ou doit prendre maintenant
en d3 dame prend des trois quarts il ya
six ce qui est sur le bord pourra
revenir vers le centre et on peut dire
que après ce coup cavaliers à 6 encore
une grande variantes pour duda qui a
déjà eu cette position à plusieurs
reprises et alireza qui avait un petit
peu traîné sur cavaliers f1 cavaliers g3
mais on savait pas c'est encore du bluff
ou si réfléchissez à la variante qui
souhaitait jouer mais
ici il a continué à prendre beaucoup de
temps et il a joué fou des deux qui
semblait pas forcément avec le coup le
plus perspective de la position même si
dans la pratique les noirs ont toujours
réussi à égaliser ici sans grand
problème exactement après food est de 5
ou de développement pourquoi pas lequel
n'a rien versé 7 b3 donc les blancs
veulent préparer à passer ces quatre
c'est pas mal tours 8 ces quatre fleuves
6 propose un peu des échanges tour à
d'ailleurs je pars ali reza alors il y
avait des variantes complexe à base de
ces cinq cavaliers 4 mai c'était la
prépa de duda on a regardé à
l'ordinateur et même si à première vue
il semblait que ça pouvait donner
l'avantagé aux blancs les noirs allaient
égaliser et duda connaissez c'est sûr
jusqu'au bout il a joué tour a des seins
qui est venue comme une semi surprise
pour pour duda mais qui a continué à
jouer assez vite parce qu'il savait ce
qu'il fallait faire tout bêtement ouais
en fait la joie cette offre qu'il avait
déjà employée il n'y a pas très
longtemps de ça donc le brut échangé les
tours une fois il a fait dépenser 4
dépensé 4 et b5 en fait l'idée c'est de
rompre la structure centrale des blancs
et de se donner des cases blanches donc
là il ya l'option prend b5 il a repris
du plomb et le rêve des north
réinstaller le calice et 7 ans des cinq
sur quoi pour l'empêcher alireza jouer
fou à 5 pour clouer ce cavalier
cavaliers c4 vient attaquer le fou est
quelque part force et la prise ce serait
idiot de revenir en arrière fou prend
dame prend cavalier e 4 vient toucher le
fou pour essayer de doubler les pions le
long de la colonne f d'amd 8
jean-christophe duda qui est pas
contraint les changes du cavalier contre
le fou on dit que les fous sont plus
fort certes mais il faut regarder les
pièces qu'ils resteraient et si
lecavalier s'échange contre le fou mais
il resterait finalement un matériel
équivalent les blancs ont un pion pas
céder les noirs auront un plomb passée
de b c'est peut-être même légèrement
plus agréable à jouer pour les noirs en
cas des changes il ya eu à 4 à 6 puis on
prend pions prend est ici c'était le
seul moment de la partie en réalité ou
alireza aurait pu
des petits problèmes peut-être avec dame
bien
balisé s'attaquer le plan b 5 c'est ce
qu'il a fait tiquer ses 3 mai sauf que
la défense est beaucoup plus à marquer
l'essai 3 l'idée d'ambea c'est de
conjuguer la tacc du pion b et des
menaces sur la huitième ranger
ça aurait pu poser quelques problèmes
pratiques après ali reza avait déjà
réfléchi très longtemps à ce moment de
la partie il a jamais
semble être dans le rythme d'un par
exemple la séquence si on revient sur
cavaliers après cavalier e cat d'amd 8
qui était un des coûts principaux mais
pas le seul il a réfléchi encore une
dizaine de minutes pour jouer à 4 sur a6
qui est quand même le coup logique il
avait repris encore une dizaine de
minutes pour prendre puis surprise il
s'est remis à réfléchir encore une
minute trente sur cavaliers ces trois là
on l'a jamais vraiment senti donc dans
le rythme dans cette partie pas très à
l'aise et après dame 17 protège le pion
tourbains attaque le pion cavaliers des
six cavaliers pro b 5 pouces est
liquidée et en fait voilà il fallait
juste voir deux fournées 4 que doux date
l'idée en fait c'est que le foot doit
être prise à cause des histoires de
mètres du couloir qui vont arriver tôt
ou tard alors oui il le prend à elle
peut être primé il va peut être gagner
en fait ont joué sur un échec tour b1
est ici le alors pas de tout reprend b1
dame prend bien dame prend des quatre
passes qui auraient matt tombé à 8
mesdames prend des quatre fins nous a
posés dans le chat la question qu'est ce
qui se passe sur tourbe et 8 les palois
et on arrivera on n'y arrive pas nature
et chloé est donc bien sûr avec les
blancs ne peut pas faire dame prend dame
si la tour prend et seimat donc il a
juste retiré sa dame en f1 mais sur quoi
user son tour d'un cran et bah c'est
complètement égal faut aussi éviter le
maître du couloir il a pêché 6 g iii
symétrie et filons ben voilà le temps et
les coûts ont été répétés vrai bon petit
nul et petite déception parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle est rezaï pas du tout
allait mettre en danger son adversaire
malgré les pièces blanches et
contrairement aux autres journées
dans la préparation de l'ouverture ça
s'est pas très bien passé on s'est
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ce sera mauvais
dans l'ouverture entre guillemets un
bien sûr et un peu mieux dans le milieu
de jeu mais non ça c'est ça s'est mal
passé on espère que demain ils
réussissent à battre
caruana ce sera bien évidemment très
difficile leur à l'eiblen fabiano très
bien préparé mais peut-être qu'il ya un
mur à moins de tensions il y aura il
réussira à montrer son majeur en tout
cas on l'espère
voilà
maintenant que d'autres villes face son
petit boulot et arrive à nous couper
tout ça
est donc beaucoup de ce jeu appelé vlad
ouais je dire ça y est le récap effet
le récap est terminée
j'espère qu'il vous a plu
et pas grand chose à dire dans cette
partie d'ailleurs on ne fera pas cette
partie en principal 1
on sait que c'est fini pour aller oui
encore une chance pour moi
demain c'est la partie de la dernière
chance je le vois pas gagner du tout
[Musique]
à
la nuit je rêve de fab et vlad qui
s'entassent qui s'entassent
langoureusement mais peut-être eu toute
une bataille avec avec vlad un peu ouais
j'ai beaucoup discuté avec vlad
moi je me mets un peu avec micha et oui
ma petite micha et oui
avec la petite dame j'appelle la petite
dame micha ait eu votre matelas allez
viens monte monte sur le siège non j'ai
pas réussir à la faire monter
mais oui nous on va aller au salon
qu'est ce qu'on entend mais voilà c'est
ton petit jouet qu'on entend au mais il
est peut-être bien ding la leur dis aime
bien h3 il n'aime pas du tout il ya
peut-être un punto faisable pour ding en
fait ça peut-être un bain de sang
aujourd'hui
donc fap toi je te laisse ici - t'as le
casque la souris mais tu peux faire tu
l'apprends copains c'est bien ouais
ouais reste là de toute façon j'ai envie
de dire je te mets un échiquier au moins
tu tombes est pas trop et je laisse un
échiquier enchaîné le hikaru puisque les
gens ont envie de le voir
qui a peut-être perdu une partie de son
avantage
mais digne que peut-être en train de
revenir elad moi je te laisse ici il
faut bien que tu parles dans le micro
par contre ce micro un peu capricieux à
la distance mais tu vas voir qu'il est
bien et tu as le fab
salanon
jeu le témoin
à l'afp
bizarre aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas ouais
ça se termine et chez
rogers
[Musique]
way
car même quand même ça a été bizarre
qu'il n'a pas joué je veux dire un truc
sur la wii
qu'est ce que je veux dire j'ai tiqué un
petit peu
donc quand le 4-2-4 de cinq chevaux de
troie fawcett au four 5 d'abord contre
fos je pense qu'on peut appeler cette
épître aux foulées pétrole chinoise oui
parce que ceux qui ont mis à la mode est
massivement à tous tout oui les mecs les
filles bon par contre à l'oeuf ou peu
plus à l'est sur jacques attali pour
cela donc on peut commencer avec tron
parce que le fouet et scotché sur 1,5
d'accord petit rock
cavaliers d2 que les déchets cet homme
pouvait pas être une surprise pour duda
parce que c'est les lignes les plus à la
mode depuis peut-être deux ou trois ans
déjà que les 2,6 d'ailleurs ici seuls
sur le coup puisque comme les touristes
auront déjà ne paie pas sûr et font
comme les deux joues tu n'existais pas
parce qu'il faut 5 1 juste un petit air
hockey coller des six normales cavaler
fond
je pense que la plupart parmi eux
jouissif au 2 3 dans des trois collèges
points je pense bon c'est que tout à
fait un autre univers eux oui la feuille
quoi élever les bouffer je sais suspects
d'avoir assez 6 et maintenant grosse
question bien sûr que les g3 wave 4 moi
je pense que normalement ils savaient ce
qu'il doit faire quand elle jouait
coluche trop
même il est très bon en fait parce
qu'après quand les g3 foudre trois dans
des trois cavaliers 6 duda a eu ses
positions déjà cette année contre
et d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'était si
bien que ça va de toute façon je pense
qu'il s'en est sorti beaucoup mieux qu'
aujourd'hui
c'était les parties double is ok faut 2
2 je sais pas peut-être se fend comme
lourdeur de coups
alors tout il offre à tous la défiance
est collé ses 7 pts 3
d'ailleurs au lieu de 0,8 peut-être ce
qui ont été intéressants 5,5 oui on a vu
que l'ordi propos et à la stonewall oui
peut-être intéressant quand même a vu la
particularité de la pression des pièces
répit donc aux locataires etc avant un
dur dont je pense que peut-être récents
qui a été le plus analysé par
peut-être donc mais après tout ce qui
est enfoui
6,7 et dur de comprendre pourquoi passer
cinq peut-être ce qu'on a cru penser
avec l'ordinateur ouais
qu'il allait rentrer là dedans mais bof
bof bof bof qui réussissent ou et
maintenant on ne peut pas défendre avec
le fou parce que collet se sentent donc
tour de en direct
et peut-être que l'éducateur on n'est
pas un bon coup maintenant
parce que je joue fosse 3
ici qu'aux livres iii et moins jeunes
ont damas trois dames cette forêt 6
faire ça mais bon mais c'est chiant ici
d'un v6 dans 9,6 g f tour de 7 j'en ai
les échos agents électoraux 8 euros
enfant tour
sans que je pense à
réaliser c'était très intéressant devant
les hauts salaires
je pense que tour bus
[Musique]
je me rappelle vaguement mais je me
rappelle que c'était dur pour les noirs
de moi dire
à quelle aune je me rappelle pas
parce que tout repos 7 à 5 ça pue à
liancourt
25 important pourra pas laisser ça est
juste pour les gens que si on prend bien
on a besoin de moi
non à 5 sur moi oui mais qui est ce que
je me disais si j'ai oublié
de tous
peut-être bokata au lieu de retour
promis cette
défend d'avoir le pion regard de la tour
pour bouffer les autres puis si ça leur
fait 100
halal elle est là quel dommage ok je
vous me rappelez plus tard hockey
d'autres façons ce qui gênait les aoc
qui s'il joue dame aux 7 au lieu de 15
élèves travaillent ici oui
oui damas et à leur chalet 89,3 g3 fuhe
cette tour de cette fosse 5 turbo 7 et
ses problématiques
pourquoi parce que en vue autour ce set
ici il joue faux bicici accès internet
et donc je pense qu'il ya un grand
problème ici il joue au lieu de football
6 2 6 8 pareil je pense que je
bokassa qatar commence
donc peut-être sur mes analyses je me
rappelle pas plus exactement les raisons
sur mes analyses et la foilleuse jouer
champions donc donné pas bouffer sur des
quatre qui est purement à oui mais de
jouer dans deux sets ici
d'ailleurs c'est un piège parce que la
bourse
dont on peut offrir en cours oui
les boyaux faire un coucou à 9,5 comme
il ya plus de coller ses cinq tours de 8
foot roi est donc maintenant elle est
noire donc je pas pu faire un coup ou
pas peut-être laissé sept jeux ça avec
un pull du mois - quoique rendait au
banc des bleus
le blocage mais bon c'est ça oui mais
pour moi c'était d'être bizarre qu'il
n'a pas juste cinq mois encore plus
bizarre je pense que je sais pas ce que
vous aviez pensé à ça c'est quand il n'a
pas fait dans boîte presque toutes les
fins au lieu de coller straw à ouidah
ben oui oui oui ça se termine bizarre
parce que je peux pas m'imaginer qu'il
n'a pas vu le coup
oui tout ça c'est normal à 4 à 6
le coût qui pouvait poser problème à
exactement parce que
peut-être deux ou trois d'ailleurs c'est
les mêmes choses se jouent ce viol
datant de 5 sur banque fait là tu peux
prendre son avec lord est ce que dans
l'autre ça et là il ya ce coup qui
défend à d'accord d'accord c'est france
[Musique]
eric dame bien ben non
et oui il ya des progrès
alors dans ce cas là les noirs sont
français de jeux quelque chose qu'on
nomme de 5 je suppose non d'un bon ouais
il a peut-être laissé trois c'est ça
plutôt d'accord lice trois autres
devraient plutôt terme en convalescence
assez chiante gf je ne sais pas
comment les pcistes jef
modérés comme les résultats
h3 plutôt je pense pour garder la case
h4 pour le cavalier ou plutôt d'acronis
3 quand même on gagne le pion au lieu de
coller
pratiquement pendant ce intéressantes
d'autres moins mais quand les c3 qui le
joue et ça a l'air tellement bizarre en
plus ce livre quand même assez beaucoup
du temps qu il avait une demi heure
c'était quoi votre version alors le quoi
c'était quoi votre
villa pense forcément fait hier ou
aujourd'hui ou hier et aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui la paix dans son
assiette il était très lent et affichait
beaucoup à chaque coup et
et puis way moins bien préparés parce
qu'en fait il n'a rien fait dans
l'ouverture d'habitude
les nobel prépare tant elle a été très
très prévisible il a tout
le temps alors hommes
les trois premiers
final
ce que donc kevin a appelé
ali reza guérin finale est complètement
épuisé ça
peut-être c'est bizarre parce que hier
et aujourd'hui comme quoi il serait
symbole pour humains non à nouveau ce
parti parce que hier elle était pas mal
et après l'ouverture quand même tout est
possible et en tout temps après fou
préfère être que les mauvaises décisions
d'accord
c'est nemo qui réfléchit d'ailleurs
d'accord et qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les parties de macao il est temps de
jeter un coup d'oeil
il n'a pas trouvé les victoires alors
c'était quoi la victoire les victoires
c'était à leur ouïe
d'abord elle est à petrov avec cave à
laisser si ce fossé au lieu de fonder si
ce
n'est pour simi a joué ça il ya juste
très peu de temps
il a fait une partie contre roanne à il
ya très peu de temps oui sinon avant
c'était toujours fondée si je suppose
donc même ça ça ne pouvait pas être une
surprise
s'il a joué récemment le faussaire ouais
donc si donc la petrov présent dans ça a
été les pitres offre chinoise on peut
dire qu'en laisser ses fossettes cll
petrov éternel oui
toujours à me dis que pour un dota moi
surtout kremnica moins au début du
siècle quelques pas
et après alors donc
avec ton un peu parce que qu'ils
viennent doit télécharger un truc et
puis donc
juste pour savoir les besoins que ce qui
est pour et asie de la ligne
où est alors donc on va voir
maintenant pas trop en fait dans cette
partie concernée pour
hikaru à employer
une souriante
que il est déjà employée contre aco
berne donc les américains en 2016
je trouve à 2 face à whitera 2 est
d'ailleurs à 20 tours à dos et tricky
comment mon cou en fait très très
intriguée j'ai compris je suppose l'idée
bien surtout radocz immense et ça donne
l'apparence assez à servir et
alors donc
attendez juste un petit peu s'il vous
plaît
quand je suis je suis parti vers ici
j'étais sûr que au dakar ou accra est
pour dans quelques coups ça pue
l'article r je me suis dis donc que iker
est un bon élève de
sarkozy parce qu'aujourd'hui il va faire
le nettoyage au karcher monique y cacher
kwessi je peux me permettre
de répéter
ou là
alors
il a raté
ce que j'ai analysé le juste raté une
victoire claire et on va voir
un peu d'auto je sais qu'il est très
douteuse mais si vous voulez c'est
comment qu'il ait dit quoi je vais dire
nettoyer au kärcher donc à
ouais
vous pourrez revoir le résumé de
à vous étiez en train de préparer le
l'analyse expression des fêtes
ouais alors on va revenir donc oui
trophée webb ellis et 6e au 7e jeu en
cours de match dans les matchs d'eau que
kasparov capot donc ces quatre le co
président parce que ici après tour en
haut lieu de fouilles cinq ans peut
jouer que valeo +4 c'est ça la
différence en fait un bail bloqués donc
ces quatre corps libre 4 c'est l'idée
même faut deux pirogues glissent 3.5
aussi c'est d'ailleurs aussi possible à
3 castro a bossé en cavale et ses 6 30
euros
8,7 des dames de 5 est ici si vous
voulez c'est une position éternel quoi
disons ça a été joué dans le match
l'écho chronique à nailloux des deux
tombes des analyses nos adversaires
aussi
je me rappelle qu ils nous on en fait
trop triquint avec leur préparation
c'est important de dire qu'il a été leur
préparation parce que ça va aider aux
explications pour les partis dans le
cadre d'accords et donc à [ __ ] 4 308
c4 dans un cat fou 3 est ici à maillot
de tourner d'analysé prêt pour six mois
le problème c'est que nous a choqués
avec la nouveauté d'un pseudo maintenant
c'est les premières lignes d'ordinateurs
mais à l'époque à l'époque les
ordinateurs donner un bon avantage bon
en gros add avantage de bois en faute a
pris d'assaut deux jeunes dames se
douche tous deux des cinq
en fait ce fric oui c'est pour ça qu'il
y en a pas trop modéré dati voilà donc
dans le dos pour simplifier les
positions parce que les noirs sont en
demande de l'espace
important alors
attiré 8 maintenant
hikaru a joué tour à deux ce que les
employés déjà en 2016 c'est quoi les dll
première mois si les noirs jouent en
cours thématiques ici donc au round 5
pour faire quelque chose pour moi dans
le braquage sur ces 4 il veut aussi des
dents de cinq tours bodin est maintenant
donc la tour pour
contrôler les colombes baisse sinon
c'était pas possible parce que o'byrne
est contrôlé et donc les menaces
tourbeux 5 et 6 e 6 c'est très très à
leurs donateurs en fait cavaler ou 5
6 4 je suppose fosse 3 au 6 x 3 x f3
d'un v6 turbo eu deux fausses et en
dames ça c'est sa partie contre
escaudain est ok les besoins ont des
supers pièces en pions du moine mais les
compensations nelly et sur le fait que
l'euro a pu être sensible parce que trop
de pièces qui vise les droits sinon le
cavalier à 5 va pas jouer pendant
prés mâles poste voilà ok il est
déterminé par gagner ça d'accord ça ne
vaut pas été une surprise pour nous pour
nos ports pourtant corrigez moi si je me
trompe je pense il est mis du temps pour
réfléchir sur
20minutes d'accord ok si des dames de 5
c 4 et maintenant on peut jouer dans le
d6 dans le 2e set et je pense que tout
est mis au même dans des os qui montre
combien sur tout mieux que fulham 4
parce que une fois les touristes adorent
et aucune raison parce que l'idée même
de dames 4 c'est d'échanger les dames
après dans le c2c l'aider même en phase
donc pour moi c'était une grosse
surprise alors
ce qui est marrant aussi que c'est mon
ordi dans burn c'est hyper hyper hyper
dangereux malgré cela c'est quand même
mieux que dans le cadre légal ce juste
mal quoi h toi tu reprends d'empreintes
barkat ok le problème est que sur danger
si c'est toujours de cavalli h 4 / / h
cinq noms avant d'abandonner il ya
toujours 2 et 4 oui
alors parce que vous je cachais dans le
cadre est toujours fou judo et ça défend
trop mais c'est des fantômes voilà comme
d'habitude le fouet sur g2 toujours très
bien pour
alller dame cat fourreau étroit
autour de jean dutourd donne
d'armes de 3 est ok il est réputé le
coup et puis donc le jeu de tout votre
heure près de trois mois ici dans cette
position séance que je ne lisais que les
quatre gagnants
oui et les détresses ans pour le sicoval
et des quatre mouvements tour des deux
joueuses gagnante pièce
parce que ce soit des quatre tombes
soient f5 ton bon enfant
non je veux dire juste dance 3 faux bond
ou en faisant ou ayant fait neuf comme
les d4 ton juste
ouais donc on ne peut pas à le reprendre
sur 10 4 sinon ok on ne peut pas tolérer
que le fou un r oui donc au fond de
cette mêlée après des cinq n'y a pas de
coups
parce que encore une fois qu'il est de
4,7 et essayer un bout sur deux je sais
pas qu'est-ce qu'il n'a pas vu le hockey
bien sûr j'ai l'air beau de comédiens de
deux nouvelles avant l'été si
intelligente et 5 la même chose
le problème c'est que la dame sur en
contrôle tout même à la casa 5 d'alcool
ici pour vivre et cavaliers des quatre
tours de deux tempêtes les pièces
blanches suis hyper harmonieuse
et ce qui peut aller là bas
tu sais très bien ici ou là bas je pense
qu'il ya une fois le covan et sur des
rythmes même si tu fais pas tu cours
donc je me suis dit alors après il voit
offrir 44 et sa voix un terrain si vous
voulez fin de la partie il catharsis
quoi
un mot doit y réfléchir réfléchi
réfléchi puis il s'est mis à jouer quoi
tous trois dans bande de cinq archipels
r pour moi
peut-être un groupe comme les ossètes
parce que maintenant c'est en est et un
merci en bourse ce sens que loupe il
peut pas prendre parce que la donne va
partir elle défend peu le flou
ouais et du coup là c'est plus simple
ouais
ok ici les résultats sont déjà prêts
medio car oui parce que le convalescent
sur ces si ce n'est pas si n'est pas
aussi bon en fait c'est vachement
compensée par les le contrôle de cases
noires les six
enfants et puis la bataille de petit
problème le foulée cacher et donc ils
ont fait nul à répétition comme ça ah
ouais ok
ouais bah dommage pour icare ou alors
carrément c'est bien de tourner à 40 ans
rapporte ça fait nul
c'était compliqué mais il ya une heure a
donc fait fuite fou je sais tout aussi
de fous je sais d'accord là aussi ça a
été très bien j'ai qatar d'ailleurs ça a
été le coup popularisé pour avoir joué
pour la première fois parmi les fours
joueurs partis et je me rappelle tout le
monde est très content parce que tout le
monde a pensé que dans cette ligne il
faut connaître et se voit les lignes
gens la connaissent et six boeufs o 2 3
ou froids ou j'sais pas quoi et oui les
futurs cadres tout le monde de voir ce
cadre est toujours donc mais les
réactions de
rapporte a été bizarre pour moi parce
qu'il faut trois bouts cinq clips ou 3,5
dans deux ou trois sets ça n'a pas les
guildes être trop bien trop bien quand
même parce que con quoi t'as pas une
très bonne version de l'attaquant
enfants si vous voulez les visions des
choses habituelles j'ai pas fourché de
f3 je sais pas qu'est ce qui est mieux
toi tes rêves coiffe au genou hausse
3,4 f3 en fait je crois ce que j'aurais
fait plutôt froid
je pense moins bons fous je dois être
vraiment garder la f4 en un coup quoi
mais les sacs lequel il est revenu et
puis du coup faut couvrir la voix et mme
othman donc
ok et les durs de critiquer son grand
drogue bien sûr
aux soldats touré font ça paraît de
terrain coût normal par contre si grande
rokhaya quoi qu elle s 4 je pense mais
les h4 conquois fou je sens que je
faisais et peut-être possible de prendre
la f4 fkt à utiliser donc 5
est peut-être celui qui veut simple et
peut-être comme ça alors elle va
contrôler les cases noires et peut-être
tu te dis que ce midi ouais ouais en
fait ça me parait de vidéos à leur tour
iphone normalement
louis lecoin 6,6 à raoul chichin compris
comme le fouet partie de la diagonale il
veut dire qu'ils ont elles pris part à
cinq ans et s est bien sûr ça fait peur
un petit peu si tu fait craindre au
casque
alors le g5 way à 5 bien sûr f 4 à 4 à
15 ans fait en quelque sorte je pense
qu'un rapport pu être un peu désagréable
en tant que l'adversaire pour aaron
parce que kavanagh est quelqu'un de très
très solide que mon jour tandis que
agressif mais solides indices qu'ils
rapportent les justes imprévisible
je pense que peut-être pour us et les
pédales et pour juste devenus sourds ou
encore les peu trop à qui paraît pas
être qu'on les prend un peu trop peut
être classique comme coléreux cette
justice qui pourrait pas être classés
comme fou 6,6 à 5,6 aussi concouru au
dos
il a fait ça du coup away parti pris 4
et ouais
ok j'ai l'impression que les bois n'ont
pas d'avantagé les résultats
d'accor et après
a été amassée bourse adacore weir wave 2
à bricoler bouge et aux 5 et ça y est
elle a cassé
la cage pour la dame aux gestionnaires
après attaque est vrai que jolie
d'ailleurs
fait
13 esthétique ou bombe alors du coup il
ya plus qu une partie c'est radjabov
dingli rennes alors peut-être falloir
mettre la caméra je les trouve à tiens
ça me rend content parce que
c'est pas la peine d'être joueur de
lille pour comprendre ce que ce soit les
noirs qui sont clairement améliorées
tiens ça c'est très agréable
ok
comment elle y réussit deux ans veut
reprendre à zéro 6 e puis on viendra où
il réalise alors ouverture
ça échec et écoute je pense que j'ai
trois déjà je pense que c'est pas archi
archi malin de jouer ça contredit donc
qui est
peut-être le mur de jeu prend il à il
est temps d'aider dans cette ouverture
que contenu catalan avec les branches
pense pas que c'est eux qu'il faut
bagadadji toujours provocateur sait il
le fait toujours donc pour normal c'est
rock falls de 5 e les trois boîtiers
c'est le plus simple contre le système
j'ai rien soir juste
je pense que ici ou trois c'est vraiment
pas intéressant au moi je pense qu'il
faut faire quand vous allez au sens que
avec des idées comme
calibre de
7,7 des oeufs des
est maintenant je pense
j'aimerais que ce soit dans laquelle
je pense but 3 juste comme ça je pense
pas que ce soit intéressant avril parce
que en cette demande pourquoi est ce que
les noirs doivent être moins bien le coc
blessures des deux tellement passive
enfin j'aime pas trop ok
ah oui oui oui
enfin bon je vais juste dire qu'il joue
pas d'âme cette aventure sweet parce que
s'il joue dans cette société à 3
il peut pas retourner sur le site oui
donc jo tour souhaitait le funk ou
d'attentes à ses fins et si tous surtout
saint jude amos est parce que il n'ya
pas de trouver maintenant les défenses
et très bien
et d'ailleurs peut-être après dames
cette année il pourrait jouer la montre
parce que bof bof bof tu
as ces bourses dans des six tours à sept
tours à huit et six tours beauce et
du coup ça va on regarde la colère
bon ça va se régler
demain 7 3 ok quand on ne sait pas qui
est ce qu'on va faire les catalans
jouent toujours 3 2 3 et d'un mode
normal
alors ce débours bouffe et maintenant
quand le sens où sûrement exactement ah
ouais
c'est une expérience de 4 c'est souvent
la faute des catalans pourquoi pas ce
que je dis pas que c'est la faute mais
ça peut ramener à une faute plus tard
parce que quand vous jouez au cadre de
les catalans souvent après vous êtes
obligé de bouger le plus bref aussi
c'est de continuer après cela il peut se
rêver très facilement que le roi devient
faible ouais au juteux de telle
expérience donc si on volait kovalev 3
par exemple 2 3 c'est toujours hyper
hyper
ce court jusqu'au 4 plus haut intérêt
messieurs mais
comme mal se passer ouais
rêve de 8 ok 4 ok ils montrent qu'ils
ont eu lieu se qualifier quoi il veut
gagner parce que c'est vrai que
s'il veut se qualifier il doit de
marquer déjà
[Musique]
d'accord d'ambassades ou voilà donc ce
que j'ai dit avant lui un clin d'oeil
sur le père
henri qu'il faut ce 5e rang
cinq chicots les cinq pires amis du
matos après d'investissement
ou presque parce qu'il ya encore tout
sera ok pas besoin de perdre le match
les cinq a reculé à 6,6 défend un brin
co valeo cette eau qui puisque de toute
manière conquois ai rien à faire sur gc
ce week end
à quoi si ce
n est
pas ce qu est le publie son truc je
pense qu'il faut quatre pratiques mois
par an c'était au moins de l'élève
paulao jouer les familles des 103
oui d'accord notre offre là ça s'aggrave
et matar samb bien sûr ah oui mais
typique une fois les pressions sur les
colons des il veut menacer h4 sur g4 que
régis et ça y est loin de rentrer dans
les trous qui s'ouvre du coup il est
bloqué mais c'est un autre os 4 c'est un
coût qui est ce que c'est compliqué à
faire ce coup là qu'est ce que c'est dur
à chaque fois l'âme entre hambourg et
matthew fox pour ça que tu es obligé ou
halal d'ornellas et ce en direct
la formation les noirs le plus haut sur
5 à 6 les pions
lebron les pions sur bris 4 à 3 et la
tour noire sur ce cadre se rappelle
quelque chose
bah non enfin
je pense que je suis je suis sûr que
c'est quelque chose mais peut-être de
savoir te rappeler quelques jours mais
tous vivre savions ce que ce que je veux
dire je pense que si je me trompe pas
c'est les premières parties que pour
blanca li kimble et quand tu comprends
que les écraser avec le tour était forme
formation
voilà
donc
il est est ce qu'une menace déjà que
peut-être juste quand les c6 oui
j'adore augmenter les pressions sur des
quatre pour augmenter les pressions sur
quatre
ne peut pas tenir trop avec les blancs
c'est trop dur ce sera versée hyper
facile de perdre à vide par contre par
contre lebron pu rejouer que les cinq
après quoi
on peut reculer la dame sur
cette petite
amaya je sais tu qui tombent d'accord
entre pas alors il faut bouffer
car le ces trois fuites autour de 3
d'accord
ok soit échec soir 7 3 au 7 ce qui peut
prendre fougeux cette
eau est sculpté ou pas
d'accord collègues dès
lors ce toit
et maintenant comme quoi et 6 et qu'on
voit sa force du liban de bouffer c'est
ici en vo
sauver le pion dangereux 5 si vous savez
le pion au large ou f5 et un jour pour
le pion c'est ça ce que tu sens qu'il
faut participer avec un sou de plus
enfin deux jours au moins lang alors il
est il faut quoi là on est là pour
regarder kiev ça ils bouffent pas
malheureux on se donne bouvet bush ouf
roy bush et donc faut pas prendre sa
retraite dangereux ok par contre leucate
et ryanair comme les trois anr joue faux
de quatre heures
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous deux au moins
on ne peut pas jouer autour de 2,9 ce
que les airois quelques parures aux gens
est-ce que c'est beaucoup
peut-être pas
agréable bien sûr losc c'est beaucoup
après un bond en avant du cavaliere
ouais tour ça alors
parce que tour à doc avait laissé son
chien
sicoval et
6,5
ou mangrove toi
colette de 5
comme quoi pédaler pour personne
[Musique]
au moins le problème c'est qu'une fois
je l'aimais il y aura comme
l'association
donc ok bien sûr un peu le jouer oui
mais je sais pas qu'ils pensent beaucoup
le premier truc que la tour défend à la
fois les deux fugueuses se retrouver je
trouve il n'y a pas d'autre il n'y a pas
d'autres blessés
c'est peut-être
à leur nom encore une fois peut-être
temps de trois tours de 3 à coller aux
sétois fit autour de trois buts pour ces
deux zèbres un an c'était d'abord alors
ça peut-être ou et bouffon
on reprend et reprend issifou jeu 7
6 5
et 5 euros qui vise les mêmes choses
d'accord et donc au carrefour de quatre
faux bond au pire ils veulent aussi que
voulez-vous trois accords les trois que
les skate au collège de hockey dangereux
quoi ils bouffent pas ok ils bouffent
pas aux
jo alors un truc comme le froid
ok certes meilleur pour les noirs mais
problématique de gagner
bizarrement peut-être elle devrait faire
une prophylaxie
contre que relève 5 soit en bougeant la
dalle soit en bougeant peut-être même le
roi
sa future recrue
obama il n'a pas trop bisons de la dame
sur des notes d'un beau
essayer de mettre la tour sur ces quatre
mois juste un coup plus tard
on va voir si ces qualifs c'est comme ça
que tu as raison tu es 5 c'est peut-être
le coup qui veulent sauver au niveau du
temps donc 12 2 me pour raj à
presque 19 pour ding cursan coup à jouer
donc
ouais si chaque élève 5 après vente chez
n'est pas ce que c'est quel point cette
7 e reprend des 3c des coups faciles
et en fait j'oubliais c'est c'est une
seule partie qui n'a plus qu'à le
nord-est il nous reste que ça finira
bien quelle journée bizarre moi parce
que c'était très compliqué partout n'a
qu'à pas partout mais n'accueille
caruana en fait je commençais dossier
voir la rondelle ça risque d'être vite
[Musique]
et donc pour résumer la position en
roaming est plutôt mieux parce que le
roi plus faible avait des faiblesses
partout mais peut-être ce couvent et des
radjabov à tenir à peu près ce que le
roi va devenir moins faible et parce que
sa voix très n'est quand même pas mal d
échanges déjà les dom déjà les cavaliers
et peut-être même les foules et tous les
toits et ça veut dire qu'il faut donc
conserver 35 ans après la liquidation
totale ont pas totalement massif et bien
sûr
ça doit beaucoup aidé aux besoins qui
sont
s'y trouvent soit la région par contre
ça peut être difficile pour les blancs
moi je pense que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi fabu que s'il faut pas
qu'à voler le 5 sur bourde de terrain de
vivable
disons que pas souvent dans le mali j'ai
sauvé des trucs avec les banques pas
souvent je pense que d'habitude je
perdais
pour moi c'est plus facile d'essayer de
sauver une finale avec un pylône du mois
a que ça que sa pression parce qu'en
fait un haut lieu de dent à part des
réelles de danger
je commence de voir poindre des fantômes
auto je me fais des désillusions en plus
quelqu'un la demande m qu'est ce que
cette nulle d'aujourd'hui à feu par
rapport au tournoi de délirer zaba ça
pas changer cette situation pour eux du
bien donc il a gâché la couleur blanche
aujourd'hui et sans trop trop trop
pressé et pourtant c'était possible et
donc il est accueilli quoi il est à mon
sens je pense que si il perd une partie
que plus ou moins c'est fini pour les
qualifs donc il n'a pas et n'a plus le
droit de perdre il doit gagner par
contre la bonne nouvelle que demande il
demande le double caruana caruana
l'os à celui qui est à la deuxième place
exactement à quoi qu'on croise mois donc
en fait un dépôt plus de wii caruana
plus un oui après à 50 % il ya ben salah
dépendent d'eux mais pour l'instant il
ya duda yann ak oui 1 rapporte et
peut-être dean qui gagne sinon non
et - 1 avant la ronde il y avait zéro
déjà dinghy radjabov
d'accord bah écoute et déjà on peut dire
un peu aussi
radja pire cela que hull et à autre
compétition il est
il voit plus haut donc ceux qui ont pu
avoir en tant que lui faire il peut
devenir le fournisseur de points ouais
comme ben naoum a été les candidats
derrière aux candidats dernier et comme
d'hab d'abord radjabov a été lui-même en
en fait le titre do carlson qui aurait
obtenu pour plus tard ça s'est joué sur
les finales grave banyuls comptera djabo
avec le fini par gagner elle a fini par
gagner la partie a duré je pas 80 du
coup il est fini par gagner comme ça
donc à la dernière ronde même s'il est
perdu au compteur de l'air cramique a
perdu au compte et venture les deux
empires diomède donc quand même il était
premier
donc elle s'est qualifiée il obtenu le
titre mais sinon
la finale était grave moigne jusqu'aux
terrasses à bord à l'époque radjabov a
été donc le fournisseur de points donc
c'est pas trop bien pour le tournoi donc
moi même si je sais pour dire que
je voudrais pas quand même qu'ils ont
déjà après cinq rondes qu'ils gagnent
tomber si bas quoi c'est quand même pato
pour le tournoi
donc j'ai des sentiments double
toit
j'aime bien digne en fait mais je trouve
qu'il est moins précis la
gâche un peu nos contrats portent contre
les assauts plus bizarre encore une fois
les lads laisser des m17 peut-être
encore une fois elecam un pub assez
bizarre quand et où les candidats qu'on
quoi il joue
moins bien paquiot que guillaume comment
dire qu'ils ont
que son meilleur niveau même moment bien
que son niveau habituel
il regroupe des trucs comme facile là
par exemple je ne sais pas mais les
pressions qu'ils groupe que les cinq ans
pourtant cette thématique comment
comment comment dire une frappe tactique
quoi
ça donne quoi nakany pour bah ça a été
nul un moment donné le chaos et des
aimants clairement sur mon ordi plus
d'un an et demi est d'ailleurs sans les
cosmétiques en faisant des coûts certes
formé bas extraordinaire
ne sait pas quand même un truc
ok peut-être
peut-être n'a pas compris les lignes où
on avait gardé
ses directs de tacler truc
à écouter sinon quand on a fait avec
deux offres
quand on a fait les pronostics avec m
qui va toucher une question importante
amende dont j'ai pas pensé
qu'ils ont il est possible que les
canicules et madrid joue
une grosse importance il est possible
qu'un
bon après la faute colère des douanes
d'armes ou de
l'ambassade tempo il est évident qu'ils
redeviennent
très très dur pour les besoins du joueur
j'aurais dit que 100% sûr qu'il va faire
maintenant autour de 3 parce que
quoi qu'ils
croient qu'ils ont à oui c'est joli
d'ailleurs est ce que tu peux montrer
s'il te plaît fab si tous deux ce joli
tour c'est dommage parce que comme les
trois
fourchettes dames 3 cavale et ce2 et un
peu pas bouffer avec le cavalier parce
que la daytona c'est assez joli quoi
donc tourbot set c'était aussi un piège
en fait
donc moi oui le jeu de dames de droit il
revient il attend d'ailleurs tous deux
une menace toujours pas à cause de leurs
nombreuses ont
d'ailleurs peut-être alors au lieu de
2,3
a
cl jour où h3 pour qu'il ya plus comme
il ya trois ans tu menace toujours pas
tourner le dos parce que tous deux dans
le dos dames quatre dames aux quatre
élèves de colo 4 en fait c'est ça le
prix à payer quand l'euro un football
bien sûr youtube il ya toujours un truc
qui arrive quoi
ok donc dans 2 3 c'est un coup typique
quand tu veux rien
jusqu'à ce que tu te sers les seuls
mais
je me trompe sûrement mais l'amant dans
l'oubli
l'amant veux je veux que vous laissez 6
pourrait charger lieu du ps qui défend
qui défend trop
peut-être je me trompe
olawale c6 l'idée était bien sûr de
bouffer avec l'au delà dans
et qu'est ce que je vois pas à un petter
sait pas ce qu'il fait là bas parce que
c'est la mode de feu c'est cool parce
que les bois no qui compte on l'affublé
ski o
[Musique]
que les bois on aussi aux quatre oui
trois oui parce qu'une fois avoir ya
plein d idées tactiques et le roi oui
donc trois faiblesses et assez beaucoup
aux kids à la finale et finale il peut
se révéler que le plongeon 3 va être
faibles comme le pion à trois aussi
parce que se trouve sur la couleur du
fois de version mais quand on parle du
milieu du jour hockey aux quatre coins
de trop à couvert roy quoi
peut-être la plus grande faiblesse de
banc c'est nouveau
et donc lui il est bien placé il bloque
un peu le fooding louise là il empêche
le kavé de venir oui parce que m en
pressant sur e4 peut-être si en force
les bandes de pousser au sens que ça va
encore affaiblir
le papy sur jeu de tête d'autres cas ce
truc oui et s'affirmer loufoque dos ils
voient plus attaquées sur je sais tu
combien l'ivoirien qu'on a montré avant
enfants il ya plein de raisons pour
faire ce
qu elle qui fait rien peut-être
l'échangé ou le bon cavalier à des
blancs prise d'un cran en doublettes
colonnes on attaque le pion et un à
rouvrir les routes vers 3
l'heure auxquelles elle devenir
peut-être il tente de remettre un
bloqueur vers la route
[Musique]
ouais c'est sûr massage qui joue au prêt
à la grèce toujours quand même pas mal
quoique rome je ne sais pas quel point
ça aide aussi à jouer au foot de 4,2 à
l'aide de quatre et soit dame ce soit
dans
broken embraces est avec les deux colis
suspects
ou la cave aux livres iii et donc il
veut absolument de 8,5
ok les annales compris en fait ce qu'il
faut briller c'est important quelque
sorte aussi pour le noir parce que le
contrôle de weezer si on fait c'est
cette
wiimote m'assure que voler f3
il verra prochainement
et oui et si tous deux ont maintenant
tous deux beaucoup d'amants non après
que l'histoire
tous deux
par exemple on bouffe en bouffe on
bouffe on bouffe en bouffe en bouffe
et les blues vont doivent viser à ses
souhaits ou peut-être les bancs vont se
promener jusqu'à ce sans coût et avec le
roi ça veut dire que par exemple
l'histoire de vos lecteurs tu peux pas
5 avec les dom et les voies n'ont pas le
cas quand les six années n'a soit
3,3 à 3,5
héros de
28,3 de 3 à 8 3 2 4 3 3 sans avoir les
boules
et là est très actif
en forme peut-être les commandes y
relève
les
comment dire trop de boulimie
peut-être espion
mais n'est pas une très bonne idée pour
les noirs et ses activités
comme ça qu'on quoi en a perdu le fil de
la partie même un peu dire mêmes larmes
de le positionner
donc quand on vise à 3 en fait les bois
donc pour on obtenait obtenir du contre
jour alors après dame de trois ils
réfléchissent à ça et on est toujours
ils réfléchissent le live onecare 6 6
mais il ya peut-être d'autres options
bien sûr
d'ailleurs je voulu dire juste qu'est ce
qui arrive si faim a
pas content ça peut s'avérer d'être un
peu double tranchant
après ils veulent sûrement jeux à 5 ça
c'est le cavalier et gagner la partie
mais depuis 600 droit est assez faible
ainsi quand quelqu'un
ou un
ok 2 jacquot quand les rues si ce ne
doit pas être bon parce que 2 tours 4 to
put mois et tours 3 arrivé et
ça se promet d'être la fin quoi
dirt 3 avec toutes les combinaisons
après à l'heure où les tours se doit
toujours collé trois la même chose
d'ailleurs vous savez mes amis nos amis
qui est ce qui arrive souvent c'est que
tu te rappelles pas d'aller partie du
truc comme commune autrement
des complices ou avec d'autres ça arrive
souvent on en fait quatre
ferries très souvent d'heure ok il
menace aux 5 alors qu'ici il joue autour
d'un est-ce que ça aide
est ce que les noirs obtient quelque
chose par contre les uns peut jouer dans
l'ue27 oui et comme quoi en maintenance
sans que gagner elle
gagner les pièces autour de 2
à juste là cette fois
oui dans le jeu autour d'eux est à
nouveau de ce qu'on peut faire c'est
peut-être non ok voici voisine regardons
5e feu
oui qui s'y colle et 5 2
[Musique]
comme les 5-9 que le 3e tour 7 à la fin
ouais
ouais ouais et tours se doit il bouffe
et qui a valu à trois le problème c'est
que si on prend pas et c'est déjà lui
qui saute
oui
bush pour la série juan m mais du roi
qui saute
alors même si vite taux de 5 ans était
la fff 1
alors que les cinq n'est pas bon alors
que voulez vous de moi du coup il est de
nouveau co 2 3 alors vient en fait la
dame sur ce we three pire bien placé
pour les aider avec au sein parce
qu'elle est là bas est la
moins pour ses incroyables or dit il
voit pas de bien sûr ça mais c'est quoi
ton
après après quoi il dira wife de quoi
oui d'accord mais
si tu joues webdav dos avec le coeur
léger site youtube stryges par contre si
tu triches terre ait jamais obtenu une
position c'est contradictoire un aqua
quant aux caisses à cette belle le cas
si elle ajouté ont eu deux dents de scie
tour de dos dames sweet tour de oui ça
m'a dit très mauvais on se bouffe et
donc on regarde tous deb a essayé de
défendre parce que la menace 5 qui va
chasser ce cavalier et on est trop
nombreux sur le pion donc toujours de
logique on essayait dame 17 pour faire
le clouage et réitéré la menace est
peut-être la seule défense et de revenir
est donc moyennement n'est pas content
de répéter on tente un petit différence
on recommence à voir faire ça et on
regardait tour 2 et 5 qui a l'air hyper
chiant pour les blancs en fait je pense
fab qui réussissent a été très très bien
comment dire quand même parce que il
reste
par hadja faire trois coups non mais si
c'était ici c'est très facile de cacher
quelque chose il y en a je pense qu'on a
bien montré quand même les aider de
noirs ici donc c'est hyper facile de
couper quelque chose - mais que trois
coups et quand même c'est très bien
parce qu'il ya tout les fourchettes et
et les clous âgées
bien reading
d'atteindre votre came fr ou h3 d'accord
ok
qu'est ce qu'il veut dire avec ça il
veut dire qu'ils ont déjà une fois
l'opinion sur six est amer maintenant il
menace quand même tous deux maintenant
au tour du double dames aux 4 à la fin
de la ligne le puy on ne s'y attendait
c'est ça c'est beaucoup quoi
dame truite
l'eau et sur le roi et rouages 2,5 et en
arrivent à notre disposition
aa oui oui ça sert she could à moudre
aux jeux à 5 parce que c'est sûr qu'il
va repartir va pas rester dans le ville
bien sûr
attia mais ça c'est l'impression qu'ici
il a prévu c'est que c'est que c'est un
pur gignoux quoi peut-être faire ça si
on peut on les met en grand pour les
deux en écoute note tiens tiens tiens
très intrigant fait très intrigant
oui vous les spectateurs après dame
solide ça vous donne envie de jeu un
rouage de où vous allez vous avez assez
des nerfs pour garder enfin le papy
anvers
la commedia la bourreuse le bourg ou
alors la bourreuse way est la bourreuse
sur ce oui toi
la grande faucheuse même on pourra dire
pardon la grande faucheuse
oui oui l'amour elle même
comme suit ça donne envie par contre oui
il est vrai que pour des raisons
purement du spectacle je suis con quoi
pour que rennes je perds pas bon par
contre le terme dérive indigne de
frapper
d'un côté et de l'autre côté quand même
le plus par deux fois ci j'ai pas de
sens poitiers privé je sais pour souhait
que je joue mieux
il irait gagner
parce que d'ailleurs pour ceux qui qui
pour les amateurs qui ceux qui ne font
que débuter aux chèques fou de 8,6
avant l'idée de mettre le fou sur brice
vous savez ce classique
vont se rappeler puis à 5
dans cette partie el loco 29e ça a été
un gros ce mois-ci qu'en fait ça me
ressemble les exercices dans les manuels
du jour positionner ici trouve un plan
ou à 5 ans un moment de la cale le
cavalier sur des 4es et fragile c'est
carrément
une classique instantané quoi
[Musique]
dérivé satan coiffure of heroes sa
fouille nul
il ya longtemps déjà il l'est reste en
fait tout est nul
n'a qu'à gagner aussi est donc
maintenant a dit yang est en train de
gagner contre eux je sais qu'il ya donc
avoir loué moins été rappelé aux anglais
donc rajaa -2 donc à partir de demande
quelque sorte il ya sept 7 candidats
sept candidats après +8 mais bon le truc
ce qui va arriver après ça il va prendre
il aura coût 40 et va pouvoir bien
réfléchir peut-être si ça a l'air très
dur mais oh oh
oui il voulait vraiment pas laisser aux
5 donc il le mesle a résolu un problème
mais il est affublé les diagonales oui
annonce ses nouveaux problèmes et
peut-être pas aussi on sait pas
ok d'accord un beauf
sur cinq n'ont
hélas ouais c'est vrai que kevin durant
le chat ding prince est la moins en
moins qui ferait que 0,6 gagne mais déjà
c'est bien pour lui il faut revenir
petit à petit quoi
bah déjà 0 comment il sait mieux que moi
tu es sur la cavale est aussi que voler
ou 5 est-ce qu'il peut jouer que le
cas le 5
ok c'est très très bon je trouve ça bien
sûr on a peut-être jallet 5 feuz
[Musique]
s à ses débuts dieu tu joues fou ce 5 va
se situer mouais y achète toi qui vas
t'en dis à tout le monde
cinq de ses six ok je veux plus
regardées faveur
ok tu bouffes de nous mêmes de nos vies
on va perdre sa non
ça c'est un peu pareil rats et dames c6
disons dame sait si c'est après que les
introduire
c'est le rêve de quelqu'un qui joue la
française car aucun cas rothen parfois
la slave donc c'est le rêve de quelqu'un
qui dès les premiers coups c'est pas
pour les cases blanches oui donc ici ça
a été notre rupture mais quand même
c'est le rêve juste là le triomphe
positionnelle ce que ne peut
abandonner car pour faire gagner une
partie fantastique avec les bois en
compte les gains et
les presseurs hausse au fournil on
appelait ça la
laci les symphonies des casques blancs
et les noirs avaient les pions sur l'a26
oui oui quand même ils sont fous sûr je
sais ce qui donc il a crié le
symphony
ici c'est d'ailleurs ici il a beaucoup
plus cocasse
à partir s'il a beaucoup plus ok
objectivement ça doit être pire dans ce
foutu moins pop et donc si vous voulez
même donc il va faire en cours
son coût que son quart est en cours mais
peut-être un peu ça va pas pouvoir
sauver parce que bah tout motard
bien de saving
les stucs crois que ding peut-être va
jouer de mieux en mieux dans le tournoi
qui n'a plus trop le jet lag wooden ce
que j'ai vu aux comptes rapporte et les
voir grand avantage peut être gagnant il
faut analyser mais ok il a réussi à
regrouper dans quelques cours hier il a
quand même pas mal précis quant au cas
où ils n ont pas mal pris c'est donc
deux fois comment elle était pas trop
loin donc maintenant plus ou moins sûr
qu'il va y arriver parce que je pense
que une fois il s'agit de quelques
contours ni roi je pense qu au packaging
en général les joueurs chinois sont
difficilement stoppé guyane décideurs
voyez aussi et donc je pense que
normalement il gagne aujourd'hui et
je pense qu'il va jouer de mieux en
mieux il est possible que demander le je
le joue encore avec les bois peut-être
donc
avait clos son moral
qui montent haut et montantes
oui je vois l'évolution enfin on voit
l'évolution de leurs dix années denis et
pour les noirs mathieu dit que c'est
presque plus simple mais je sens sur wii
wii moitié au havre il a raison je suis
sur un message sur un bonheur dit et ça
va donner plus un lit plus 5 sur son art
devrait plus accès à
la condition qu'il faut pas faire des
coups extraordinaires mais ici il paraît
que non oui c'est pas un sacrifice
après il faut prendre quatre alors qu'on
tombe les cases
blanches qui le noir contrôler si ces
quatre bien je cadre excellente f5 où ça
va frapper sur le droit de savoir que
sur le web etc sont des cinq excellents
les diagonales à 8h à d'un coup à l'auto
paris
en gros les 5 comment s'appelle
le corps les artères 5 artère très
important
ces rencontres aller pour le noir bas et
en plus un peu moins de pas dire que les
bons contrôles trop les artères des
cases noires un peu moins ne pas dire ça
donc en gros donc positionné mal à faire
dans le sacre il suffit alors bien le
prendre c'est peut-être ça c'est un truc
mais
hélas on élimine on gagne cette case
mais d'ailleurs souvent c'est un bon
réflexe donné le fou contre un cavalier
bon contre les couleurs opposées
oui oui parce que les noirs le viol donc
band est déjà à 100% le contrôle de
cases noires donc et le camp blessures
des cadres est le dernier obstacle c'est